beaucoup
mes chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
deux nouveaux pour évoquer après nos
travaux l'année dernière puis le groupe
de travail qui avait travaillé dans la
sein de la commission des affaires
économiques sur la question du zanu nous
retrouvons donc aujourd'hui pour
poursuivre nos travaux comme le sénat
nous nous y invite c'est à dire qu'une
fois que la loi est votée nous essayons
de voir si la loi est applicable
appliqués et quelles améliorations
potentielles nous pouvons en attendre
nous sommes particulièrement heureux
aujourd'hui de recevoir pour cette table
ronde l'association des maires de france
voilà qui est ici je laisserais chacun
se présenter l'association des maires
ruraux de france sait pas si vous êtes
ils sont par visio je crois c'est ça
merci jaune à peine son par visio
l'intercommunalité de france et france
urbaine qui qui est ici donc merci
beaucoup de votre présence pour faire un
nouveau point d'étape sur 7 sur cette
mise en oeuvre du volet than de la loi
climat résilience à bientôt un an de
l'adoption de ce texte qui est née je
vous le rappelle la fameuse convention
citoyenne nous continuons en effet de
suivre avec attention la mise en oeuvre
des dispositions votées par le parlement
ce que prévoit la loi fait figure de
petite révolution pour les politiques
locales de l'urbanisme s'est pas devant
des associations élus que je vais dire
ça elle implique bien sûr de modifier en
profondeur une part des documents
d'urbanisme et de repenser l'équilibré
politique
les injonctions aussi des politiques
publiques qui sont celles du logement du
développement économique des mobilités
et bien d'autres je parlerai de la
renaturation des problèmes de transition
climatique et énergétique le tout bien
sûr sur la forte contrainte qu'exercent
les préfets nombre de paramètres
importants avaient été laissés au décret
dans la loi or dès mars de cette année
les élus locaux et notre commission des
affaires économiques avait alerté sur
les projets de décrets qui s'éloignait
de l'esprit de la loi et apparaissait
inapplicable l'état par les
collectivités le gouvernement les a
pourtant confirmé il y a quelques
semaines de cela le 19 mai dernier la
commission des affaires économiques et
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
ont donc lancé une consultation des élus
locaux via la plateforme en ligne du
sénat nous avons reçu et nous les en
remercions
1250 réponse qui confirme que de
nombreuses interrogations remonte de nos
territoires sur l'application concrète
de cette fois face à la forte
mobilisation du sénat dans son ensemble
mais aussi les associations d'élus
rompant avec le silence du gouvernement
jusque là le ministre christophe béchu
s'est déclaré il ya une semaine lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
ouvert à la réécriture d'une partie des
décrets et a appelé les associations
d'élus à réfléchir collectivement aux
modalités de mise en oeuvre du than et
alors il faut qu'ils soient rassurés
parce que vous le faites nous faisons
donc globalement on va pouvoir y arriver
mesdames et messieurs les représentants
des élus locaux c'est pour prolonger
cette réflexion que nous vous avons
proposé de participer à cette table
ronde comment après un an d'adoption de
cette loi concevez-vous aujourd'hui les
années son déploiement sur le territoire
français qu'attendez-vous du
gouvernement notamment sur les décrets
mais aussi sur l'accompagnement des élus
peut-être qu attendez vous aussi du
parlement et nous vous demandons en
effet au sénat nous nous demandons si la
méthode retenue est la bonne peut-être
faut-il également des aménagements
d'ordre législatif le ministre a je
crois reçu vos associations
pourriez-vous nous dire quelle est la
teneur de vos de vos demandes
enfin au delà des seules mesures de la
loi climat résilience quel chantier
nouveau nous faut-il ouvrir pour trouver
un modèle du than celui de la fiscalité
par exemple comme l'a abordée jean
baptiste blanc dans la président la
commission des finances je salue le
rapporteur général un général qui est à
mes côtés
devons nous parler de compensation voir
aller jusqu'à des nouveaux éléments de
décentralisation ou qu'elle nous sommes
particulièrement sensibles ici au sénat
à une méthode ascendante plutôt qu'à une
méthode descendante voilà des champs de
questionnements que je vais vous poser
sont également conviés à cette table
ronde nos collègues sénateurs issus
d'autres commissions qui ont travaillé
spécifiquement sur le sujet du than
monsieur blanc gelé cité tout à l'heure
monsieur le rudulier monsieur le mans
délit monsieur anglars monsieur biya qu
différentes commissions et tous la même
préoccupation celle de l'application
l'applicabilité du than dans les
différents territoires et donc je
remercie le rapporteur général jean
françois husson d'être là au moins au
début de cette réunion marquant ici
l'importance que représente aussi 7,7
cette disposition de la loi pour la
commission des finances concernant le
déroulé de cette table ronde nous vous
proposons une séquence en trois temps
après un propos général de chacune de
vos associations nous aborderons
successivement trois aspects du than sur
lesquels vous pourrez vous exprimer
librement d'abord l'état des lieux de la
mise en oeuvre du than le financement
est ensuite intimité matic plus large
qui est les années la ruralité parce
qu'on a beaucoup de deux sujets qui nous
remontent voilà deux particulièrement au
sénat nous prendrons ce bien sûr ensuite
les questions de nos collègues jean
françois tu veux dire avant peut-être
pardon oui merci
madame la présidente moi je je m'associe
évidemment ou souhaite bienvenue et
surtout je souhaite qu'on puisse
travailler dans les meilleures
conditions sur un sujet comme la vie
sophie climat particulièrement complexe
une fois que le dispositif ait voté sans
moyens mis en oeuvre d'où le une
quadrature du cercle patiemment délicate
à
à laquelle il faut répondre et à trouver
les moyens de mise en oeuvre et à cet
égard je veux saluer le travail de jean
baptiste blanc qui est parti d'une
feuille d'une copie blanche ce qui est
quand même un des paradoxes parce que je
pense que vous c'est certainement ce que
beaucoup pensent
ça toujours une vertu de d'imaginer des
dispositifs mais c'est mieux de proposer
des dispositifs bien organisé bien
charpenté c'est pas du tout le cas avec
lausanne
on peut soit tout envoyer bouler soit
essayer de trouver un dispositif parce
que il ya au moins une chose qui est
sûre c'est que on a collectivement quel
que soit le niveau de responsabilité à
trouver des solutions sur la manière
dont on pense pouvoir
continuer à vivre dans de bonnes
conditions avec le plus dignement
possible sur notre territoire et même
sur notre planète on peut choisir de
s'exonérer de cette responsabilité je
crois que non il ne faut pas le faire et
le fait d'organiser ce temps des changes
me semble important parce que il ya à
trouver non seulement des éléments de
compréhension mais des débuts de
réponses pour construire un projet le
plus collectif possible répondant à de
multiples interrogations qui vont faire
l'objet de ces tables rondes on pense
tout savoir une part de vérité pour la
réponse le plus difficile maintenant ça
va être de pouvoir faire sans boiter
les différents points de vue en essayant
de se comprendre je crois qu'il faut
accepter de se dire qu'il a encore
besoin d'un peu de temps mais je
remercie et je pense que c'est bien le
rôle des du sénat qu d'être à la
manoeuvre dans cette réflexion il vaut
mieux prendre ses responsabilités
débattre que d'imposer et et en mettant
tout le monde dans la difficulté donc
bravo merci madame la présidente et
merci à toutes celles et tous ceux qui
contribueront à ce travail collectif
merci beaucoup sur rapporteur général je
vais vous passez la parole pour environ
5 minutes de propos liminaire ensuite on
passera aux thématiques si vous en êtes
d'accord ça vous convient voilà je parle
aussi à ceux qui sont en visio et que je
remercie d'être là je vais passer la
parole à l'association des maires de
france peut-être pour un propos
liminaire cher alain chrétien merci
merci madame la présidente alain
chrétien maire de vesoul président de
l'agglomération ancien député je
représente aujourd'hui david lisnard
notre présent de la mf je suis
accompagné de nos collaboratrices la mf
depuis le renouvellement
est dans son bureau exécutif appuie son
action sur trois qualités trois
objectifs la liberté la confiance et la
subsidiarité un mot qui est cher au
président lisnard et naturellement cette
problématique du than vient s'opposer
frontalement à ces trois objectifs
défendus par nos collectivités
adhérentes et arrive aussi dans un
contexte de fortes inquiétudes de fortes
inquiétudes financières
avec les propositions du gouvernement de
poursuivre la recentralisation de la
fiscalité des inquiétudes
pour les marchés publics avec
l'explosion du coût des matières
premières des inquiétudes sur
l'explosion de nos dépenses de
fonctionnement même s'il prenait 10 est
une bonne chose la valorisation est une
bonne chose ça pèse sur nos
collectivités et naturellement ce than
vient s'ajouter à ces problématiques qui
suscite de l'inquiétude
chez tous nos adhérents alors
naturellement la mf est favorable à cet
objectif de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
la mf rappelle que le territoire et le
patrimoine commun des français de par
l'article du code de l'urbanisme sont
des fondements essentiels que nous
n'oublions pas et il faut aussi noter
les efforts déjà réalisés
par un grand nombre de collègues pour
atteindre cet objectif de sobriété
foncières avant même l'approbation du
zen puisque on se rend bien compte que
l'évolution de consommation foncière
s'est ralenti depuis maintenant une
dizaine d'années parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'il ya une prise de conscience
pas besoin d'avoir voté les ânes pour
que certains de nos collègues pas encore
tous on y reviendra merci atteint
certains de nos collègues se rendre
compte que nous avons aussi un rôle à
jouer dans cette maîtrise foncière qui
concourra à la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
les positions de l'est mais dernièrement
son peuvent être prises comme des
positions un peu forte on reviendra sur
le recours devant le conseil d'état des
deux décrets que vous évoquez même la
présidente mais sachez que le président
en lice l'art le bureau exécutif est
tout à fait heureux de cette de cette
démarche du sénat qui permettra nous
l'espérons de revoir la rédaction de ces
décrets de convaincre le gouvernement
qu'il faut prendre du temps qu'il nous
faut prendre du temps collectivement
pour que cela ne soit pas subi mais soit
approprié par l'ensemble des politiques
d'aménagement local mais si même la
présidente de cette première partie
beaucoup je vais donner la parole à
l'association des maires ruraux de
france
alors qu'il doit être en visio
c'est bien ça madame la présidente des
représentants le président michel
fournier tout d'abord merci
merci au sénat de nous réunir ce matin
une fois de plus au vu de l'enjeu et des
effets qu'il va y avoir sur nos
territoires il est clair qu'il faut
réinstaurer un dialogue de co
construction dont effectivement
ascendant qui viennent qui partent aussi
des territoires ruraux des territoires
de façon générale et qu'ils puissent
présenter l'association des maires
ruraux le retour que l'on nation terrain
effectivement est très inquiète tout de
suite et pour reprendre les propos de ce
que disait mon collègue alain chrétien a
tout de suite ce n'est pas dans les
territoires ruraux
une grande consommation tout de suite a
pu se produire depuis quelques décennies
on a la chance dans nos territoires des
réserves de biodiversité des réservoirs
natura 2000 d'avoir la qualité une
qualité d'eau excellent de protéger
entre guillemets toutes ces âmes unité
qui font que l'équilibré là entre le
rural et de leur pacte lie mais derrière
tout ça effectivement madame la
présidente une inquiétude forte depuis
un an et demi peut participer avec mon
collègue françois dekker est si présent
à toutes les réunions
proposées par les ministères en vue de
la mise en place de soan des grandes
inquiétudes on se doit de se rappeler
que le nombre de nos communes sont
encore revenus
il n'y a pas des pays partout dans
certains nos territoires il ya un permis
de construire par an quand on a dit ça
effectivement ça ne solutionne pas grand
chose mais ce que l'on croit en nous et
effectivement c'est qu'on a besoin
d'avoir un droit au projet et dans ce
gros projet je ne sais pas s'il faut
l'inscrire on y reviendra plus à l'heure
sur des surfaces réels annuels et ainsi
de suite puisque derrière tout ça on
sait très bien que ça marche très peu
mais ce qui est sûr tout de suite c'est
que moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
d'une réelle anticipation de tous les
services de l'état et ce tableau qui
nous est contraint à marche forcée
avec des délais complètement fou nous
permettrons pas dans un puits
co-construction effectivement et de la
prise encore de nos territoires ruraux
donc dans un contexte où l'on parle de
relocalisation de réindustralisation
d'un coût de l'énergie qui complètement
infernale
avec des communes qui sont très
inquiètes sur leur capacité financière à
faire des choses dans les mois et
semaines qui viennent on est
effectivement très inquiet je rejoins
effectivement ce qu'a pu dire nos cours
de ce qu'ont pu dire le collègue de
l'association des maires de france on a
besoin de temps on a tous nos collègues
et nos collègues qui sont de certaines
communes bien plus petite est bien trop
petit qui ne sont pas entouré de
collaborateurs qui maîtrise le sujet eux
mêmes les élus ne sont qu'un train de
découvrir pour certains le sujet donc
madame la présidente effectivement on a
besoin de tant de cette écoute et de
cette interaction que vous contribuez à
faire vous les sénateurs pour défendre
effectivement nos territoires ruraux
mais cette notion je reviens bien sûr d'
équilibre on n'est pas là pour être dans
une opposition rural urbain on est bien
là pour être complémentaire avec une
respect des enjeux de chacun je ne serai
pas plus loin dans la présidente merci
pour cette première intervention
par communalité de france pour prendre
la parole en visio j'imagine
bonjour bonjour
mesdames et messieurs désolé d'être en
visio j'avais prévu d'être physiquement
avec vous mais j'ai un petit souci de
santé qui élimine ma mobilité donc merci
de nous donner la possibilité d'être à
distance via la via la visio donc je
suis un autre sébastien sébastien
miossec du finistère qui représente un
autre sébastien qui est sébastien martin
le président de notre association donc
même président-délégué
d'intercommunalité de france qui
regroupe environ un millier de
l'intercommunalité en france sur les
1200 interco qui existent
sujet du zen qui est évidemment un sujet
extrêmement important sur lequel notre
association s'est beaucoup mobilisé dans
les changes de ce matin et dans les
documents qu'on pourra vous répondre
qu'on pourra vous apporter par écrit on
fera notamment référence à un
questionnaire qu'ont adressé à nos
adhérents et qui a recueilli environ 160
de réponse aucun échantillon somme toute
assez représentatif et questionnaires
qui date du mois dernier donc avec des
retours intéressants qui viennent
rappeler l'importance politique du sujet
les inquiétudes fortes qui peuvent être
exprimés je rejoinds pour une bonne
partie sa cuvette exprès par mais mes
collègues de la msdf
mais qui rappelle aussi des opportunités
qui peuvent relever de ce nouveau ce
nouveau modèle dire aussi en
introduction que le travail que mène
intercommunalités de france on essaye de
le mener en concertation avec nos autres
collègues des associations d'élus celles
qui sont présentes autour de la table ce
matin celles qui sont aussi présentes
dans nos locaux à
adouber rouge ou vert à paris donc
notamment france urbaine qui est
présente ce matin mais aussi la la
fédération nationale des agences
d'urbanisme la fédération des scot de
deux acteurs qui sont indispensables
dans le
réflexion sur le sujet du yuan
sur ses propos introductifs je voudrais
insister sur nos trois éléments d'abord
que le sujet du zen et un sujet
évidemment technique dans le sens où il
ya s'interrogent beaucoup d'éléments
techniques de nos politiques publiques
mais c'est d'abord un sujet politique
qui questionne réellement le projet de
territoire de chacun de nos régions pour
soi dans nos communes ou dans
intercommunalités de pour ce qui
concerne le club local qui remet en
question aussi d'histoire les volontés
de développement de nos territoires
donc c'est important de
l'avoir parfaitement conscience le
président us on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure voilà on a un choc
remise en question profonde de nos
modèles mais on n'a peut-être pas assez
pris le temps de voir comment on pouvait
intégrer ce changement de donne l du
côté notre association souhaite
souligner le fait que dans ce
questionnement et ce changement de
modèle les intercoms sont sûrement
souvent au coeur de la réponse
pour deux aspects d'abord parce que sur
ces questions foncier d'urbanisation de
développement l'échelle pluri communal
voire à l'échelle de plusieurs communes
dont l'échelle territoriale de
l'intercommunalité c'est forcément une
échelle à prendre en compte penser des
solidarités locales pour penser aussi
les réponses en termes d'ingénierie
puisque l'intercommunalité même si ce
n'est pas le cas partout en france
puisqu'elle et les transferts de
compétences sont pour partie obligatoire
mais pour un certain nombre encore
largement facultatif mais les intercoms
plus ou moins ont tout en envisageant
entrepris les thématiques en matière
d'aménagement de développement
économique d'habitat de mobilité de
réseaux d'eau d'assainissement qui sont
autant de politiques publiques qui
pensaient à l'échelle intercommunale
permettent de répondre aussi à cet enjeu
d'économie de essentielle et puis dire
aussi que le
lausanne
nous impose un vrai changement de
paradigme je l'évoquais mais un
changement de paradigme qui doit
mobiliser très largement les acteurs
publics donc nous sommes là les communes
les intercommunalités avec nos
départements de région qui nous
accompagne sur beaucoup de choses l'état
évidemment à nos côtés mais aussi tous
nos outils publics de type agence
aménageurs et c'est donc les acteurs
publics d'une part les acteurs privés
d'autre part tous les professionnels
liés à la construction à l'urbanisation
à l'aménagement logement y compris les
professionnels de l'immobilier les
constructeurs les agriculteurs aussi qui
qui serait évidemment concernés et cette
mobilisation des acteurs publics et
privés doit aussi conduire à ce que nos
habitants intègre cet objectif visage
puisque ça questionne fortement pour son
milieu urbain et rural ou périurbain
l'imaginaire l' envie d'habiter les
habitudes de pensée notre projet donc
sur sur tous ces sujets on a beaucoup de
positions partagées avec nos collègues
des associations d'élus notamment sur
les décrets des attentes en matière de
moyens financiers ou de calendrier mais
on aura quelques propositions un peu
particulière aussi régulière à interco
de france et je propose de vue que je
suis déjà quasiment cinq minutes de ne
pas y revenir dans ses propos
introductifs allait revenir dans les
trois thématiques merci en tout cas nous
permettre de contribuer à ce débat fort
intéressant merci monsieur le président
délégué et je dois à titre personnel
vous saluer particulièrement parce qu'
on a célébré ensemble un mariage à riec
sur belon donc voilà c'est un petit
pincement au coeur de vous revoir je
vais laisser passer par la parole pardon
à france urbaine heures je ne sais pas
madame laigneau c'est vous qui prenez la
parole même ligne merci madame la
présidente donc je tiens à vous
remercier d'avoir organisé cette cette
table ronde nous y avoir invité le sujet
on vient de le constater est
excessivement important était enfin le
mot n'a pas été prononcé pour le
territoire une véritable révolution dans
le domaine de la de la prise en compte
des problématiques d'urbanisme donc je
je voulais dire en préambule que france
urbaine et je représente je voudrais me
présente et peut-être tout d'abord
excusé moi je suis je suis vice
présidente toulouse métropole en charge
de l'urbanisme donc et plonger plonger
dans la mise en oeuvre d'un nouveau
pèlerinage donc
comment jusqu'au cou donc je mesure et
je pèse les difficultés les difficultés
de l'exercice et je suis chargé ici de
représenter ou de porter la voix du
président mondain qui ne pouvait pas
être là et qui m'a chargé de d'être de
le remplacer et je tenais à dire c'est
ce qui m'a fait penser à
cet oubli ce qui me fait que la position
de france urbaine et de jean luc moudenc
c'est bien l'alliance des territoires
c'est faire en sorte que tous les
territoires ne soit pas en opposition
donc il n'est pas question ici de poser
le l'urbain au rural sachant que dans
les territoires métropolitains
nous avons aussi du rural donc nous
avons à la fois des communes très dense
pour lequel les problèmes se posent
beaucoup moins mais nous avons également
des territoires périurbains et des
territoires ruraux donc nous sommes
vraiment
finalement nous nous rassemblons toutes
les problématiques qui viennent d'être
évoqués nous partageons et effectivement
tout ce qui a été évoqué alors je ne
reviendrai pas sur sur le
l'approbation ou la position de france
urbaine par rapport à la loi bien
évidemment nous inscrivons dans le cadre
de cette loi et les vertus de la loi ne
sont pas ne sont pas à rappeler ici
certains l'ont rappelé nous sommes aussi
très très attachés à des propos qui
viennent d'être évoqués la confiance les
territoires la subsidiarité bien
évidemment aussi et nous contestons de
la même façon s'il a déjà été fait par
france urbaine le caractère descendants
de
l'application de la loi et et le peu de
prise en considération des différents
territoires donc cela cela déjà été
exprimées et justement la parution
l'apparition des derniers décret si on
aurait pu espérer une clarification dans
le temps en temps dans la loi pour ma
part n'a fait que complexifier me
semble-t-il enfin pour ce qui me
concerne n'a fait que complexité
complexifier l'exercice donc on se
trouve dans des dans des situations de
risque même de risque de risques
juridiques sur la mise en oeuvre de nos
de nos documents dans un dé qui a été
rappelé qu' d'être excessivement court
est bon je vois là donc je n'en dirai
pas davantage parce que nous aurons
l'occasion probablement de deux de
développer nos positions tout au long de
cette conférence et j'aurai l'occasion
si vous me le permettez et si vous mais
autorisée de d'exprimer d'exprimer le la
vie d'un élu qui est vraiment confrontés
très qui s'est plongée dans le dans le
sujet du pmu h dans un contexte un peu
particulier puisque notre paix lui h
antérieures que nous trouvions vertueux
à plus d'un titre a été annulé par le
tribunal administratif pour un motif
d'intérêt privé donc c'est un aspect que
je souhaiterais sur lequel je
souhaiterais questionner peut-être des
parlementaires parce que un sujet
d'intérêt personnel donc un intérêt
vraiment personnel a déclenché un
véritable séisme
c'est l'annulation d'un document
d'urbanisme de portée générale et
d'intérêt général donc là il ya un vrai
sujet et j'insisterai peut-être un petit
peu là dessus tout à l'heure je vous
remercie très bien merci beaucoup madame
la vice présidente alors le premier
sujet sur lequel nous vous proposons
vous exprimer l état des lieux de la
mise en oeuvre du than tous autour de
cette salle dans cette salle nous avons
eu des retours des élus de nos
territoires qui témoignent parfois est
encore là madame la vice présidente une
sorte de grand flou et parfois d'une
franche inquiétude je souhaite dire ici
que personne je crois dans cette salle
ne remet en cause le bien fondé de la
démarche de sobriété foncière que nous
défendons depuis longtemps qui déjà
intégré vous l'avez dit monsieur le vice
président de la mfr
politique local d'urbanisme c'est la
méthode qui semble générer beaucoup
d'incertitudes et de réticence donc est
ce que vous nous le confirmer quelle est
la qualité de votre dialogue local avec
l'état avec la région et en l'état des
choses les collectivités pense-t-elle
pouvoir tenir les objectifs fixés par la
loi à la fois en termes de délai mais je
crois avoir compris la réponse est en
termes quantitatifs et bien sûr quels
sont les principaux points de blocage
sur ce premier sujet je vous redonne la
parole dans le même ordre voilà pour
plus de facilité
merci le vice-président à la présidente
sébastien gouttebel l'a dit n'oublions
pas que environ 30% des collectivités
locales ne sont pas dotés de documents
d'urbanisme pas de carte communale pas
de paix élu communal encore moines p lus
intercommunale et son eau qu rnu donc ce
débat il est totalement étranger aux
préoccupations de ces mères qui eux ne
peuvent eux mêmes pas de délivrer de
permis de construire et donc avant de
vouloir imposer un than à tout le pays
parce que naturellement on l'a dit c'est
une mesure dogmatique technocratique et
donc inapplicable et qui est en
contradiction totale avec notre
triptyque que je répète liberté
confiance et subsidiarité donc avant de
vouloir imposer les ânes à l'ensemble du
pays commençons déjà par faire
comprendre à nos collègues
que en tant que maire ils sont
dépositaires du patrimoine national qui
et quels territoires et qui doivent à
ensemble réfléchir parce que
naturellement le pnud ne peut se
concevoir qu'au niveau intercommunal est
là aussi la mf est claire oui mais
n'obligeons pas nos collègues à rentrer
dans une démarche qu'il n'accepte pas
expliquons leur convainquons les c'est
là qu'on a besoin de dde et je parle pas
de voler je parle notamment de dde pour
vous trouver la mosquée des dieux qu'on
connaissait ya quelques années avec des
ingénieurs de l'état qui était là
parfois un peu contraignant parce que
c'était encore décentralisation
balbutiante une bonne vieille d'aidé qui
savait parler aux élus avec le sub dit
du coin c'est comme ça qu'on arrivait à
travailler alors qu'aujourd'hui on a
cette loi au niveau national et plus
grand monde entre nous l état central
donc la première chose c'est d'essayer
de faire comprendre à l'ensemble de nos
collègues que chaque intercommunalité
doit se doter d'un projet de territoire
et donc de l'outil paix et lui
intercommunale c'est un travail de fond
qui n'a pas été aboutie qui n'a pas
encore été réalisé et tant qu'on n'aura
pas fait comprendre ça à tous nos
collègues comment voulez vous qu ensuite
on leur demande de mettre en place ce
than je rajouterais ensuite que la
nébuleuse galactique des sera dette et
des scot est totalement étrangère à 90%
de nos collègues
j'enlève peut-être l'adjoint à
l'urbanisme
les vice présidents à l'urbanisme qui
parfois sont invités convoqué au conseil
régional du coin pour parler de tout ça
la conférence des scot reste malgré tout
à grand emprunt
technocratique
qui finalement va accoucher d'une souris
ou dire qu'on ne peut pas aller plus
vite que la musique donc on a en plus de
cette
difficulté un certain nombre de nos
collègues qui ne sont pas sensibilisés à
ça une démarche qui est totalement
déconnectée de la réalité
avec cette conférence des scot mais je
ne nie pas la qualité des travaux je dis
simplement que l'association sur le
terrain n'est pas suffisante et nous
avons demandé à ce que tous nos pead est
soit systématiquement invités sur tous
ces sujets là ils ne sont pas
systématiquement et quand ils le sont
ils sont un peu la cinquième roue du
carrosse puisque les choses sont déjà
bien engagées et pour terminer cette
première thématique du débat c'est le
coup
quand vous savez qu'un scott ça coûte au
bas mot 500 mille euros
bras même plus
quand il faut demander aux élus de
mettre cinq cent mille euros pour faire
un scot qui parfois mettre dix ans il
faudrait qu'on fasse aussi le bilan avec
la fédération des scot le nombre de
scott qui sont toujours à l'étude qui
sont bloqués par l'état ou par les
associations par les uns ou par les
autres
donc quand vous rajouter le coût de
révision du document d'urbanisme qui
vient s'ajouter à sa les élus non
seulement ils trouvent que lausanne
c'est un handicap supplémentaire et que
c'est des coûts supplémentaires et
confère à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure quand on voit les couilles qui
explosent en termes d'énergie entre m
5000 euros de plus dans le scot et
100000 euros de plus pour payer le
courant dans les piscines ou dans les
écoles le choix est vite fait donc ça il
faut quand même pas le négliger
et puis pour pour terminer je pense
qu'il est essentiel que
le gouvernement exprime et christophe
béchu il a dit vous l'avais dit aux
dernières qu âge et sa volonté de revoir
complètement la copie quitte à faire des
aménagements législatifs parce qu'on va
le voir est ce un objectif ou une
contrainte lausanne et les décrets qui
sont qui sont parus et vous l'avez dit
ma chère collègue madame la vice
présidente nous met dans un flou
juridique total et cerise sur le gâteau
pour terminer après la complexité la
déconnexion et les coûts bien c'est
l'incertitude juridique qui pointe
auprès de tous nos documents d'urbanisme
donc voilà en résumant cette première
première thématique vous avez compris
que on n'était pas très content de la
tournure des événements c'est assez
clair l'espèce étant je vais donner la
parole à monsieur le président gouttebel
à
madame la présidente je vais essayer de
ne pas faire de redites l'intervention
mais effectivement que l'on soit
l'énergie du désespoir qu'il faut mettre
tout de suite pour écrire à tous les
présidents de région pour qu'on puisse
siéger autour de la table on est dans
une méthode où les peuples se faire on
essaye de rentrer par les fenêtres donc
excusez moi un peu l'expression mais
pour favoriser le dialogue et la
construction je dis pas ça de façon
générale puisque dans certaines régions
ça s'est fait relativement bien il n'y a
pas de sujet par pons sa dette et aux
prises de contact mais il n'empêche que
pour siéger autour de la table ça
devient vraiment vraiment laborieux donc
là aussi pour entrer dans une méthode de
construction et ne pas subir les choses
pour apporter des messages et justement
revenir sur ses droits au projet qui
doit pendant tous les territoires ça
vient quand même très compliqué donc je
passe là aussi tout danblon peyo
administrative là aussi on voit bien et
toutes les réunions auxquelles on n'a
plus participé et contribué ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on est dans un monde
où seuls les techno parle aux techno
merci pour le petit clin d'oeil sur les
d eux les dde ça restait mon métier un
moment de ma vie effectivement ce
maillage territorial manquait tout de
suite ne pouvait l'ignorer monsieur le
président hariri tessa
mais derrière ça effectivement
il est temps aussi d'aborder une chance
parce que effectivement l'objectif
d'être plus vertueux de nombreux
territoires étaient déjà très vertueux
donc donné aussi à ce qu'ils étaient
moins encore plus encore des droits
seillière c'est aussi une politique
potentiel du mauvais élèves ce qui est
quand même assez frustrant revenir
derrière tout ça avec nos collègues de
l'association des maires ruraux en
demande aussi en parallèle de toutes ces
discussions qu'on a plus à voir on s'est
dit tiens après tout allait construisant
un peu moins dans les territoires ruraux
puisqu'en protège tout ce patrimoine
incroyable l'agriculture la forêt l'eau
et ainsi de suite mettant en place une
taxe un fonds spécifique pour la
rénovation du râle parce qu'il ya un
moment il ya la rénovation urbaine d'un
moment il ya aussi la rénovation rural
et quand on voit le potentiel qu'il y a
dans nos territoires pour faire de la
rénovation effectivement du bâti ancien
et une demande forte puisque le co vide
a été sur certains territoires un
phénomène d'accélérateur à voir des gens
qui reviennent dans cette ruralité qui
nous est cher moi je n'ai pas d'états
d'âme et nous n'avons pas d'états d'âme
à dire qu'on peut toujours
malheureusement taxer la création de
locaux commerciaux de bâtiments
d'affaires et des choses comme ça on
zone métropole et en zone agglo
d'agglomération or puisque au vu du coût
du mobilier de toute façon ce soit en
métropole dans l'agglomération les gens
les portois projet 20 on est bien donc
quand eux quand on voit tout ce ce
potentiel et 7 non prise en compte on
doit être très très inquiet
effectivement madame la présidente sur
la méthode mon collègue tout à leur
parler des coûts j'étais dans lost en
villégiature les quelques jours
entendent la communauté de communes du
secteur où j'étais en vacances parler de
500000 euros pour un plh 700000 euros
pour 1 p lui qu'il n'arrive pas à finir
et qu'ils ont du mal à finir avec
remettre ça sur la table dans les jours
semaines qui arrivent les élus on peut
tenir pour dire clairement les choses
les coûts financiers sont tels que je
dirais par moment malheureusement ou
heureusement nos populations n'ont pas
conscience et ne savent pas ce que ça
coûte derrière aussi pour nos
territoires donc merci madame la
présidente pour cette partie là mais on
demande effectivement du dialogue de la
concertation et une prise en compte de
nos territoires merci merci monsieur le
président mon temps votre halte au feu
monsieur miossec pour intercommunalités
de france monsieur le président
merci madame la présidente je
n'aurais peut-être pas le même temps que
mes collègues nez mais je partage aussi
beaucoup de leurs inquiétudes et remonte
aussi notre territoire je fais référence
ou telle oeuvre au fait qu'on a fait
passer un questionnaire à nos à nos
adhérents qui nous fait remonter en
effet beaucoup de beaucoup d'inquiétude
y compris sur la façon dont les choses
se passent techniquement et pratiquement
les politiquement aujourd'hui même si
je tiens à redire quand même que
beaucoup de nos collègues nous disent
c'était par
les interlocuteurs précédents mais
l'importance l'attachement qu'ils ont à
pouvoir intégrer réellement dynamique de
moindre consommation foncière et de le
penser dans une approche globale sur le
développement de leur territoire donc
certes beaucoup d'inquiétude mais quand
même une mobilisation réelle des élus
sur le sur le terrain pour autant il ya
des il ya des difficultés on est là pour
l'aider identifiés pour essayer d'y
apporter des réponses
et notamment sur le côté on va dire sur
le portage politique de la chose les
conférences des scot sont en effet
totalement satisfaisante à l'aria des
questions de délais qui sont souvent
évoqués et nos associations ont demandé
au gouvernement de retravailler la
question des délais un courrier commun
préparation de plusieurs de nos
associations donc j'espère que nous
serons conduits là dessus pour nous
donner un peu plus de temps mais malgré
tout l'échelle de la conférence de
nadège code reste une échelle à
s'éloigner du terrain qui mobilise plus
tôt des spécialistes et
alain chrétien évoqué beaucoup de nos
élus sur le terrain ce qu'ils vont
mettre en oeuvre concrètement lausanne
sont extrêmement éloignée des échanges
qui peuvent varier en conférence dé
scott des échanges très souvent
construits argumenté intéressant mais
mais comme très loin de très loin du
terrain donc côté intercommunalités de
france on insiste pour que cette échelle
de la conférence des spots et son rôle
on ne remet pas en question et il faut
qu'on puisse avoir une capacité alors ça
demande du temps mais c'est aussi de la
méthode à pouvoir faire redescendre les
réflexions les les arbitrages à des
échelles plus proche du terrain
ça et jusqu'aux communes mais les
jugements intercommunale peut être du
mal à mobiliser de façon très fort
pendant plusieurs régions de france on a
eu des retours de nos adhérents nous
font part que la région au delà de la
seule conférence et scott
vous avez un dialogue direct aussi avec
des intercommunalités au vu de ce que je
disais en introduction sur la capacité
des intercoms à mettre en oeuvre
beaucoup de réponses aux liés aux ânes
que ce en matière d'habitat de
développement économique et de tous les
autres compétences que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure donc bien le plus fort entre les
régions et les intercours et puis de
réfléchir peut-être aussi à une approche
plus contractuels c'est à dire que les
objectifs de réduction de la
consommation foncière doivent en effet
se discuter à une échelle large le sras
dette malgré sa complexité et
probablement un outil c'est probablement
comme mieux que ce soit à l'échelle de
nos collectivités que les choses se
pensent plutôt qu à la seule échelle
nationale 1 même si le sras dette et ça
a été dit aussi c'est compliqué à faire
vivre la territorialisation est aussi
compliqué à traduire dans les faits mais
on a du coup besoin que neichel plus
proche du terrain donc puisque
contractualisé entre acteurs l'état et
des communes et intercommunalités d'un
côté mais avec les régions aussi pour
pouvoir au delà de l'objectif décrire le
chemin les moyens dont on a besoin pour
atteindre lausanne
les contrats de relancer transition
écologique les certains qui sont d'une
qualité très inégale en france peuvent
toutefois être peut-être un espace là où
en tout cas ça s'y prête à traduire dans
un contrat les la mise en oeuvre de du
chemin pour atteindre pour atteindre
sinon je m'étends pas sur une des
questions de décrire ça a été évoqué par
nos collègues et je crois qu'on sénat
vous ètes bien au courant des remarques
on a pu porter sur le contenu technique
de décret
rapidement d autres questions sur les
grands projets vous évoquez aussi le le
traitement des grands projets on a comme
une contradiction là aussi à a donc
vouloir le année on partage l'objectif
ça a été dit mais aussi vouloir
réindustraliser notre pays nos
intercommunalités sont très nombreuses à
nous mobiliser pour
pouvoir participer de cet effort
national de
réindustrialisation est donc faux on at
elle réellement la mesure de la chose
pour ne pas comment dire ne pas
finalement aboutir à une à cacher les
efforts qui sont mis en oeuvre sur le
terrain par les collectivités mais
accompagné aussi et par l'état parce que
d'un côté on aurait des effets
contradictoires en termes de
consommation foncière et de
réindustrialisation donc interrogation
forte sur le sujet est de notre côté
donc on en pense que réindustraliser
elle doit intégrer malgré tout cette
question de l'économie foncière mais là
où la réindustrialisation et le
développement nos industries contribuent
réellement à la transition écologique on
doit pouvoir faire un effort pour
consacrer une part de la faune sied à
cette thématique donc le lausanne en
tant que tel c'est un objectif louable
mais mais ont probablement continuera
qu'on savait du foncier toujours donc
notamment on répondra des fortes de
développement et l'adaptation de
territoire assez aux impératifs nous re
du modèle économique
post crise autre lieu
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
président madame la vice présidente pour
francs sur pen alors je ne m'attendais
pas aujourd'hui entendre parler de la
dde parce que moi aussi dans un autre
temps j'étais junior
je m'attendais pas du tout à ça parce
que c'est vraiment au regard des
quelques années je voulais seulement
dire qu'à cette époque là les services
de l'état étaient au service des
collectivités
voilà était et ça j'avoue que je ne
retrouve pas le jeu retrouve pas du tout
cette cet état d'esprit dans les dents
les nouveaux fait rouler les collègues
qui sont actuellement dans les d'été
c'est ça n'est plus le cas donc je moi
je le regrette très fortement c'est
comme ça donc c'est assez c'est assez
amusant mais je voudrais souligner le un
point important qui que je n'ai pas
entendu mais qui concerne à la fois la
mise en oeuvre du zoo dans le cadre des
scot ou de la ou des métropoles bien
évidemment c'est là
l'objectif annecy réuni tout le monde
parce que tout le monde est favorable à
cet objectif qui est un objectif on l'a
déjà dit à la fois ambitieux mais aussi
vertueux mais divise puisqu'il nord qui
ne réunit et au sein d'une collectivité
mon jeu le jeu le vit au sein de la
toulouse métropole les différentes
communes ne comprennent pas et puis et
puis et puis veulent construire ne
comprennent pas cet objectif global et
je vous assure que ça
génère des divisions entre élus et des
frustrations et ne parlons pas alors au
niveau d'une métropole il ya toujours un
président qui arrive à are fédérer tout
le monde donc on peut y arriver au
niveau d'un haut niveau d'un d'un scot
ou d'un syndicat mixte d'étude de death
quote bah c'est pas du tout le cas moi
je préside le syndicat mixte qui a en
charge le scot de la grande
agglomération toulousaine
c'est du sport chaque chaque réunion je
vous assure c'est ça divise les
territoires ça la divisibilité mais j'ai
un collègue de la ms qui présidente de
msf locale avec qui nous nous discutons
mais c'est ces violentes parfois les
discussions sont parfois violents et ça
c'est pas normal voilà la zenn
l'application du than a tellement
complexe complexifier que finalement
c'est devenu c'est devenu des sources
d'opposition sur sur un sujet qui
devrait finalement nous fédérer parce
que l'objectif est vertueux je tenais à
le dire parce que je le vis je le vis au
quotidien et je pense qu'une des
solutions et cela est évoqué par mon
prédécesseur et qui démontre bien que
nous avons travaillé avec les différents
partenaires c'est la contractualisation
avec l'état donc il faut partir du
territoire il faut que les territoires
qui le soumettent où tous les
territoires mais individuellement puis
se contracter avec le avec l'état pour
pour pour
sur des objectifs sur des objectifs de
sobriété foncière sur des objectifs de
d'artificialisation non
artificialisation sur sur l'application
du than et ça ne peut se faire que à
partir du territoire avec les services
de l'état et ça pourrait même avoir un
effet vertueux c'est que mais on aura
peut-être l'occasion de
le développer ou d'un aparté de
sécuriser juridiquement les
les stratégies foncières des
collectivités des opci parce que il
devrait y avoir me semble t'il à un
moment donné une position de l'état qui
valide je dis ça parce que notre paix
lui a été annulée pour moins que ça hein
donc il faut absolument bordée de bordés
la stratégie des collectivités de
manière à ce que un jeune un juge
surtout un avocat zélé n'aille pas
chercher
voilà une mauvaise interprétation de de
la loi pour le
pour la cette stratégie foncière donc je
voulais aussi insisté sur un point c'est
que les
on constate beaucoup de gens qui sont
contre a dit contradictoires les
communes quelles qu'elles soient sont
tenus de construire et de produire du
logement social et certaines de ces
communes ne disposent pas de foncier
donc devront consommer dnas fort il faut
plus consommer des nymphes donc à un
moment donné il y as on se trouve dans
des dents des dents des dents des dans
des situations qui sont parfois des
situations critiques pour certaines
collectivités et on se heurte à la
position ferme et féroce de l'état et
donc ça c'est un coup quand même pour
les collectivités ce point là aussi et
surtout surtout ça en effet un effet
désastreux pour la production de
logements je voulais insisté également
sur le sur le sur les outils qui sont
bien qu'ils sont mis au service des
collectivités pour pour faire cette
cette analyse les toutes les tout pour
compter pour dépendre pour
identifier les lésés n'a fait et pour
travailler là dessus et l'eau csg ou qui
est l'outil finalement le détail puisque
c'est un outil d'hygiène pour nous et
l'outil vertueuse sauf que il n'est pas
développé sur toute la france donc free
oui mais
s'il n'y a pas d'outil incontesté et
incontestable
pour pour identifier
l'état des lieux est ce que l'on fait on
n'y arrivera pas non plus donc une
position assez ferme de la part de
france urbaine pour qu' il y ait un
effort qu'ils soient portés pour
généraliser un outil cet outil qui
existe que certains utilisent que nous
utilisons mais que que toutes les
collectivités ne sont pas en capacité
d'utiliser et qu'il ya
d'autres ont parlé de vous parliez tout
à l'heure de coups de l'élaboration d'un
pillage nous en avons marre un qui a été
annulée d'un coup de baguette magique
mais c'est ça relève du million d'euros
et nous recommençons voilà donc ça les
cours les coûts sont assez considérables
je voulais insister sur un autre point
qui me paraît essentiel aussi c'est que
il
ne faut surtout pas pénaliser les bons
élèves
certaine que depuis vous avez souligné
que depuis quelques années il y avait
quand même une tendance une prise en une
prise en compte de la 2 des problèmes
d'étalement urbain et lescott précédent
pour beaucoup ont anticipé et ont
essayé de 2,2
d'imposer la sobriété foncière dont on
rêve tous alors plus ou moins fortement
mais certains ils sont arrivés donc il
ya des métropoles et des opci qui se
sont inscrits dans cette dynamique là et
qu'ils ont et qui ont freiné la
consommation foncière et ses opci sont
pénalisés puisque déjà l'effort a été
fait pendant quelques années et cet
effort doit être décuplée maintenant
vers ho / deux minima pour pour
respecter les objectifs de de la loi
certains territoires sont moins
dynamiques ou non n'ont pas eu cette
cette vertu là et finalement ce seront
favorisées puisque maintenant il dispose
de deux davantage de foncier pour
pouvoir continuer à faire ce qui faisait
auparavant donc voilà je je souhaite je
souhaite peut-être insisté france
urbaine souhaite insister sur ce but sur
ce point la faire en sorte je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait on avait
imaginé que des décrets allait améliorer
la situation et je vais voter
rêvons pas on a lu la même chose
rêvons pas c'est pas comme ça que ça
s'est passé donc le donc voila ce point
ce point est important puisque je
voulais dire que les livres parce que
les métropoles françaises du 22
métropole française je crois qu'elle
représente un tiers de la population est
important l'artificialisation des sols
donc les métropoles malgré tout
j'entendais que les territoires très
très ruraux ne consommez pas bien sûr
mais les métropoles finalement quand
globalement on regarde ça de près non
plus même si
elles doivent prendre leur part à
l'exercice malgré tout et puis il ya un
point que je qui a été évoqué que vous
avez évoquées dans vos questions mais
qui est pour moi excessivement important
c'est les projets d'envergure nationale
et régionale donc si avec régions de
france peut arriver à trouver des
critères pour caractériser les qui
relève de la de la région des projets
d'envergure régionale pour ce qui
concerne les les projets d'envergure
nationale
c'est un point d'interrogation
je voudrais citer un exemple qui est
excessivement en frappant sur toulouse
vous savez tous que toulouse métropole à
une activité industrielle florissante
dans airbus on construise difficilement
déjuger les unes sur les autres donc de
l'intensification dans ce domaine là
c'est un peu compliqué donc et airbus a
besoin d'un espace donc oui airbus
regarde c'est
gère aussi son patrimoine son patrimoine
industriel de manière à ne pas les céder
des hangars lit de l'a380 s'est arrêté
la chaîne d'assemblage de l'a380 a été
réutilisé bien évidemment mais malgré
cela airbus a des besoins ces besoins
ont été chiffrés à une centaine
d'hectares pour l'avion décarbonés
message insiste sur l'avion décarbonés
l'avion décarbonés sa robe cc c'est un
autre niveau face à un autre impact que
l'impact purement régional vous en
conviendrez tous et airbus
elle n'aime pas le régional est certes
important mais l'impact national n'est
pas n'est pas neutre il a dit on est
décarbonée pour moi c'est même plus
national c'est à une autre échelle donc
airbus s'il n'a pas les 100 hectares il
par hambourg voilà donc
la question se pose qu'est-ce qu'on fait
200 hectares nous avons d'autres
capitales de foncier à consommer pour
les dix ans à venir elles sont sur la
métropole toulousaine de 650 ha si nous
avons airbus mais il ya un pas que nous
avons la ligne lgv nous avons
l'autoroute toulouse castres donc des
infrastructures lourdes qui skie qui
sont alors c'est vrai que là et je vais
va servir toulouse enfin mais c'est
quand même une ligne grande vitesse
d'intérêt d'intérêt national me semble
t'il donc comment identifier qui qui
peut caractériser qui peut accepter que
certains projets bien alors je citais
toulouse mais
le canal seine nord par exemple je
tombais jamais j'en ai je peux vous en
citer puisque je surveille mes mais je
voulais c'était quand même toulouse
parce que je pouvais pas ne pas le faire
voilà merci madame la présidente je vais
vous couper pour passer peut-être à
notre deuxième thématique je commencerai
à linverse par une transparence urbaine
qui est le financement du than notre
collègue jean baptiste blanc qui est ici
a rendu il ya quelques semaines son
rapport sur ce sujet spécifique de
nombreux élus mais vous nous le
confirmerait s'inquiète qu'une part
d'une part de l'insuffisance des outils
des de financement du recyclage des
friches de la rue nature à sion de la
rénovation et d'autre part de
l'inadéquation de la fiscalité qui fait
peser sur le bâti une grande part de la
ressource des collectivités et peut
avoir des effets incitatifs à
artificialisés et il est vrai que
l'annoncent de la fin de la cvs pour les
intercommunalités en particulier plus le
than ça fait beaucoup pour trouver des
ressources pour les collectivités
territoriales en tout cas c'est un sujet
comment voyez vous les choses faut-il
des guichets dette qu'elle tels que le
fonds friche que le ministre d'ailleurs
a annoncé vouloir pérenniser peut-être
même renforcé ou une refonte générale de
la fiscalité du sol ou les deux
d'ailleurs quelle part respective de
l'état des collectivités les
contribuables devrait-il prendre dans le
financement du zen et peut-être
pourriez-vous nous parler de l'impact
immédiat du zen sur les finances des
collectivités mais vous l'avez déjà fait
tout à l'heure notamment en abordant la
question du coût des documents
d'urbanisme ya aussi le coût de
l'abandon des projets d'aménagement
lorsque l'on avait fait des
investissements je veux tu être
commencer à l'inversé commencé voilà par
france urbaine
ont la côte nord madame la vice
présidente et je vais la côte et oui je
suis un peu bavard mais votre pas de
souci parce que là je vois là je sais
c'est un peu compliqué d'en démarrer oui
donc je n'ai pas nous n'avons pas au
niveau de france urbaine une recette
magique pour dire voilà le système qui
va falloir mettre en place pour pour
financer ces lausanne mais c'était il
est évident qu'il faut il faut des
dispositifs fiscaux pour freiner pour
freiner la vendirent là la spéculation
la spéculation foncière et on le voit
dès à présent les parkings les tout
bâtiment tout bâtiment un peu obsolète
prenant prennent des valeurs qui sont
des valeurs fold en matière de lorsqu'il
ya des sessions donc il y a des
de la spéculation qui se met en place
donc c'est des dispositifs fiscaux
maintenant je n'ai pas le je n'aime pas
le je ne suis pas une je ne sais pas si
fiscaliste je crois qu'il faut je pose
le problème alors vous avez évoqué le
sujet la renaturation et je trouve que
c'est qu'elle est intéressante mais j'ai
plus qu'une cuisine que j'ai même si je
trouve que c'est un excessivement
intéressant pour rééquilibrer puisque
c'est le sens aussi de la loi 1 2
d'artificialité des artificialisés puis
de l' équilibre mais j'ai cru comprendre
que on ne parlait d'artificialisation
des artifices alisation qu'à partir de
2031 donc je m'interroge moi parce que
je n'ai pas de réponse nous nouons
nature ont actuellement bonjour par
l'exemple de tous j'en suis désolé parce
que je le connais c'est celui que je
connais le mieux mais y en a d'autres y
en a d'autres mais nous sommes en train
de re nature et tout un secteur qui
était une ancienne une ancienne
des congrès voilà ne pas de congrès et
d'expositions sur sur sur une île l'île
du ramier et nous avons deux toutous
déconstruit et transformé en jardin donc
nous avons re nature et donc nous
rendrons la nature ce ce qu'il avait
perdu nous allons faire de même pour la
piste la piste de delà de la piste de
l'ancienne piste d'air france qui qui
est une piste bitumée que nous allons
transformer en forêt urbaine mais ça
n'aide pas décomptés
ça n'est pas décompté donc est ce que
ces pertes y faire je pense que c'est
toujours pertinent de le faire mais est
ce que ce sera décompté après pas pour
l'instant dans l'état du décret pour
l'instant ça ne l'est pas alors les
coûts de la renaturation c'est coûteux
ça a un intérêt pour la pole pour la
pour la pour les métropoles et pour les
collectivités c'est indéniable au milieu
bien bien sûr sauf que c'est inquiétant
de voir que ce ne sera décompté que dans
dix ans mais c'est loin en disant c'est
à la fois très bien loin et puis je
voulais parler les friches donc bien sûr
abonder le fonds friche donc pour une
fois là je peux pas vous citer tous
parce que nous n'avons pas donc il n'ya
pas de friches ou très peu mais c'est
vrai que les les territoires ils sont en
perte en perte de 2,2
d'activité bas il est absolument
nécessaire de renforcer le fonds friche
pour parce qu'il ya des problèmes de
pollution qui sont importants donc je
pense qu'il ya un gros effort de la
colle au delà de la part de l'état en
matière de fonds aux friches
je n'enchaîne pas les y allez y
messieurs
si j'avais compris on fait dans le sens
inverse est
très très synthétique mans puisque le
temps passe mais on transpose retrouva
très très spontanément sur ces sujets
avec les autres associations élus je
salue avant tout le travail du sénateur
blanc sur le sujet qui pose beaucoup de
beaucoup de pistes donc je vais pas
m'étendre insisté sur trois éléments
juste un évidemment à l'instar de ce que
me dira ma collègue de france urbaine on
a besoin de conserver des enveloppes
conséquentes pour aider les projets et
les actions dans les territoires qui
contribuent à la reconquête des friches
donc de france riche et très bien perçus
sur sur le terrain même si il faut qu'on
puisse malgré tout à l'instar de ce que
sénateur blanc a dit dans son rapport de
simplifier les choses avec un une
question de toucher unique et à
travailler deuxième remarque c'est celle
de la de la chaîne de valeur du foncier
et du bâti qui est fortement questionné
depuis déjà quelques années mais encore
plus par le par les ânes qui met
l'ensemble des acteurs privés et publics
face à un nouveau modèle est donc la
valeur des comparatifs des biens entre
le foncier en extension et le bâti les
opportunités en densification au
questionne beaucoup la chaîne de valeur
donc il faut que l'on puisse
penser complètement le le modèle du coup
de fiscalité locale c'est ma troisième
remarque pourtant tenant compte de cette
nouvelle chaîne de valeur pouvoir
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui vaut
aujourd'hui de l'argent et sur quoi on
bâtit durablement un système de
contribution des acteurs locaux aux
ressources de nos collectivités
historiquement la fiscalité locale elle
est basée sur le stock de biens sur
l'habitat et pour une bonne partie où le
bâti économique pour une autre partie et
nos recettes étaient la croissance dans
leur cet été a été
corrélée à la croissance de ce
patrimoine même si le than ne veut pas
dire zéro nouvelle construction puisque
la densification est une situé aux
portes unités pour autant sa re
questionne fortement le modèle d'une
interrogation qu'on ne résoudra sûrement
pas ce matin mais une travail à mener
entre acteurs et les collectivités
doivent évidemment être étroitement
associés pour repenser le modèle de la
fiscalité locale qui est lui-même déjà
beaucoup attaqué est remis en question
par les différentes suppression de taxes
passé je pense notamment la taxe
d'habitation ou à venir avec la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises cvae qui n'est pas indexé au
foncier ce qui était d'ailleurs 1 1 une
de ses qualités même si elle savait
aussi les défauts mais en tout cas un
modèle de la fiscalité opel locales à
repenser fortement et pour le le le
rendre cohérent avec cet objectif
duduzane donc
interco de france est évidemment
disponible pour ce travail à côté du
parlement et notamment du sénat
très bien monsieur le président pour
leïla mrf
merci madame la présidente
parler du fond finish effectivement ci
doit être pérennisé augmenter si les
communes rurales arrivent à s'en saisir
facilement il faudra juste x à peu près
par 1000 agences
[Musique]
il est dur tout de suite pour une
commune rurale d'ait dans une bonne
opportunité pour avoir accès aux fonds
friche qui soit sur mon secteur à moi
devons aussi du sancy thermales ou
touristique puisqu'il n'y a pas que des
friches ministre yelle aussi sur nos
territoires lourd dans l'eau si
malheureusement quelques écueils du
passé qui traîne derrière tous ces
financements
ne pas oublier qu effectivement les
producteurs d'énergie qui sont à la
recherche tout de suite de terrain dans
nos territoires ruraux pour faire du
photovoltaïque pour faire de l'éolien
pour faire tout un tas de choses ben
paye des taxes et effectivement il
pourrait bien qu'une partie de cet axe
ses taxes et de ses recettes la reste au
niveau local et cette fois ils soient
rares gars c'est justement au niveau
national ce qui nous permettrait
peut-être d'abonder défend dans le
département tôt pour aider justement les
communes rurales oubliées à lille ces
lieux d'implantation de cette nouvelle
richesse et des nouvelles productions de
nerfs après tout pourquoi pas je crois
ce chiffre en plusieurs milliards
d'euros donc ça pourrait être une piste
effectivement de solutions
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure je les
coupe et tout à l'heure sur la création
d'un fonds dédié ruralité pour la
rénovation du bâti ancien puisque
effectivement longtemps qu on conçoit
que ne s'étale pas et qu'on protège nos
territoires qu'ils soient donc il reste
qualitative qui la qualité des paysages
la qualité d'autres bâti il faut que les
gens qui qui qui et quand ils achètent
puisse trouver des aides dédiées au delà
des aides réglementaire de l'anah
quelque chose de ce site là qui sont
quand même réservé à certaines
populations à certains ménages
juste le fait du bien de parler du than
de parler tout ça on voit quand même une
envolée des prix
qu'on soit nous alors n'a pas cette
chance là clairement c'est que le lg b
on sait pas ce que c'est on a un tout
soupe kim à paris ce qui fait que je
suis là en vision aujourd'hui
on peut parler du lyon turin a
effectivement qui est une autre qui est
une autre source de richesse
mais derrière tout ça on doit quand même
une flambée l'augmentation des prix même
dans les territoires ruraux tout de
suite puisque les gens bien compris que
les terrains allait se raréfier et il ya
une forme de spéculation tout de suite
et les communes si on peut faire de la
prévention et des choses de ce type là
il ya un moment on n'aura pas des
finances nécessaires mais mansart des
outils les ep est fait ainsi de suite
locaux ont des tas pour arriver à faire
de la prévention on va être contraint
financièrement donc là aussi il faudra
peut-être nous trouver des solutions
pour qu'on puisse toujours présenter
pour préserver un équilibre est
justement éviter ce phénomène pas
dans tous ces choses là le retirer on
l'a oublié et je crois que macaulay de
l'adie de france urbaine thaler
l'objectif en deux étapes il ya le 2030
et le 2050 et j'ai oublié je m'en excuse
je crois beaucoup de services ont
tendance à anticiper le 2050 à l'horizon
2000 26 dont on a je veux bien qu'on
travaille tous de façon justement pour
la préservation pour la sobriété on est
tous d'accord mais il faut raison garder
aussi est arrêté d'anticiper les choses
sur 20 ans avec vingt ans d'avancé si on
veut arriver à pour construire quelque
chose et dans nos enjeux effectivement
sur le financement se rappeler
collectivement que ça fait deux ans que
les équipes municipales ou internes ou
bhl et donc du coup par effet induit les
intercoms et j'en passe et des meilleurs
ces deux ans qui ont été laborieux et
compliquée qui était où on arrive juste
à l'émergence des nouveaux projets de
territoires qu'ils soient communaux ou
intercommunaux
effectivement reste mid risque d'être
sacrément mise à mal aussi dans ces
notions d' équilibre puisque
malheureusement les territoires ont
souvent tendance est en opposition les
uns contre les autres comprendre les
grands enjeux du moment de la santé mais
de la santé sûreté des maisons de santé
c'est un exemple parmi tant d'autres
madame la présidente mais effectivement
on est là effectivement à votre écoute
et on sera disponible aussi pour vous
faire les remonter des inquiétudes des
solutions qu'on croit vous trouvez merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président et
pour terminer monsieur le président
merci même la présidente vous admettrez
quand même que c'est très surprenant
dans la démarche de créer un outil et
d'ensuite de se demander comment on le
finance sa part dont deux sans doute de
faire une redite mais je pense qu'il
faut qu'elle soit faite et que si les
choses avaient été faites dans le bon
ordre
on n'en serait pas là bref c'est ainsi
en tout cas il faut pas d'impôts than il
faut surtout pas que la conclusion de
nos travaux ce soit la création d'un
impôt than parce que là
ça ne contribuera pas à la sérénité de
nos débats futurs
deuxième élément c'est la limite des
exonérations fiscales
zrr adverse et vais donc pour les
centres-villes tout ça part d'une bonne
volonté mais on se rend compte que les
dispositifs sont pas connus que les
effets leviers sont pas forcément
efficace on a une mission nouvelle à
émettre sur ce sujet pour faire des
propositions sur
déjà évalué l'impact des rae rae savoir
comment on peut modifier cet outil est
donc on se rend compte que les exos
fiscales non pas une efficacité aussi
évidente que ça donc c'est pas forcément
là dessus qu'il faut qu'on assiste comme
mes collègues naturellement nous
relevons le succès du fonds friche
pourquoi c'est un succès parce que là
c'est pas de la dépense fiscale 1 c'est
pas de l'exonération c'est de l'argent
sonnant et trébuchant qui vient
compléter les déficits d'opération
quand vous avez quand vous sortez un
projet dans une ville moyenne la 5000
euros du mètre carré qui va acheter un
appartement à 5000 euros du mètre carré
dans une ville moyenne
personnes ça veut donc dire qu'il faut
mettre x euros pour redescendre le prix
de vente à 1800 2000 de 1200 euros du
mètre carré ça ça fonctionne parce que
c'est visible
et donc c'est une bonne nouvelle que le
gouvernement souhaite pérenniser ce
fonds friche qui à mon sens ne doit pas
être réservé territorialement donc
peut-être une dissonance par rapport à
notre collègue sébastien bou de belles
sur un fond dédié ruralité je pense que
petite ville villes moyennes grandes
villes on a tous ce sujet plus ou moins
dans nos politiques et puis
à mon sens le fond friche doit être
alimenté au niveau national il faut
surtout pas qu'on ait des fonds friche
délocaliser alors la dge qu'on a aussi
saisi à au ministère des finances elle a
totalement contre elle ce qu'elle veut
c'est des outils décentralisée
collectivités débrouillez vous entre
vous pour financer tout ça c'est la
compétence des régions fait un contrat
avec les régions pour financer le fonds
friche mais la dge refuse absolument un
fonds friche au niveau national parce
que on a tout de suite compris que ça
coûterait au budget de l'état et que
personne ne pourrait abonder sauf que
c'est la seule manière d'éviter
ce que j'appellerais de la péréquation
foncière
c'est à dire que je vends des droits à
construire
où je négocie des droits à construire
est naturellement les plus forts qu'ils
négocieront au détriment des plus
faibles il faut surtout pas qu'on rentre
dans une péréquation foncière parce que
là on va encore engagés à accentuer les
difficultés du monde rural ou des
difficultés du monde urbain
quartiers prioritaires ou une petite
ville en difficulté par rapport aux
angles zone qui se développe donc cette
fiscalité ne doit surtout pas avoir
comme conséquence une péréquation
foncière horizontale comme on connaît
les péréquation financière horizontale
mais une péréquation financière
verticale ou la taxe d'aménagement
supplémentaire puisque pour nous la
place d'aménagements est sans doute le
vecteur fiscal le plus efficace pour
financer ce fonds friche qui serait
remonté au niveau national et qui ne
fonctionnerait plus haut niveau de
l'appel à projets mais qui serait à fond
friche quand y'en a plus y'en a pu mais
tout le monde dépose et dossier
régulièrement et ensuite c'est géré au
niveau national peut-être par une agence
lines été ou ou je ne sais qui qui
pourrait proto colisée le financement
des projets d'urbanisme en fonction des
contraintes locales
donc pour nous la taxe d'aménagement est
sans doute le vecteur le plus efficace
la mf
a beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet de
sujets et on a délibéré à l'unanimité il
ya quelques années pour proposer une
augmentation de cette taxe d'aménagement
vous allez dire c'est un peu un impose
admet un bon impôt et à vielle impôts
évitons d'en créer un nouveau utilisons
ce qui existe déjà et celui là nous
paraît pertinent
au niveau 2 du financement du than on a
aussi vu une amélioration cadre de la
loi 3ds sur la maîtrise des biens sans
maîtres ont passé de 30 ans à 10 ans
mais les biens sans maîtres sont quand
même relativement rare dans nos communes
le notaire arrive toujours à trouver
le petit fils du petit neveu la grand
mère
comment voilà c'est ça allez faut d'un
bien sans maître on a un bien avec un
vieux maître voilà c'est ça et c'est
très compliqué pour nous
on est plutôt pour des opérations type
opah ru l'opération d'aviation habitat
en rénovation urbaine qui nous permet
d'exproprier des biens vétuste avec un
maître mais vétuste là aussi c'est un
frein quand on a des verrues dans les
centres-villes et que personne ne veut
vendre il faut exproprier donc quand on
était bien quand on a un bien avec m et
qui veut pas vendre il faut faciliter
cette opération là et puis enfin
n'oublions pas le développement des
foncières alors il ya les ep f certes
parfois ça coûte cher pour les petites
collectivités mais la caisse des dépôts
est en train de mettre en place des
foncières commerciales foncière
d'habitat je crois un objectif de 100
foncière ou pour pas dire de bêtises
mais sur tout le territoire de
du pays et donc les foncières peuvent
être un outil pour décharger les
collectivités de la charge foncière et
dans le cadre de petites villes de
demain ou d'actions coeur de ville ce
sont des outils qui nous permettront
d'aller plus vite et pour terminer pour
pas être trop long je crois que le point
central de notre discussion de ce matin
la président de la vice présidente
annette leignon l'a évoqué c'est la
différenciation
je crois que c est ça va totalement à
l'encontre
du zen tel qu'il est envisagé
c'est pardon mais on remet en cause le
fondement même de cette loi c'est que
nous souhaitons la différenciation et
qui est complémentaire de la liberté de
la confiance et de la subsidiarité c'est
la différenciation le printemps
république c'est un mot qui lui est cher
donc il faut qu'on s'en serve ce soutien
présidentiel et que cette
différenciation comme l'a dit la
vice-présidente nous permettra de
traiter différemment des situations
différentes et puis enfin je vous fais
l'économie vous l'avez sans doute vu des
huit types de surface qui vont être
applicable en 2031 eh ben je je je
tirerai mon chapeau au service urbanisme
d comme comme quand elles devront
distinguer les surfaces qui sont
hétérogènes et artificielle avec un
mélange de matériaux non minéraux donc
là on verra bien le type d'essence qu'il
faudra mettre sur une toiture pour
qu'elle soit considérée comme
artificialisés ou pas j'imagine une une
belle jurisprudence paysagère et
horticoles ça va être très sympa dans
les années qui viennent mais non
seulement on se rend compte que ce
dispositif est inapplicable parce qu'il
ne tient pas compte des différences
entre les territoires et que quand on
rajoute la loi élan la loi l'alluré la
loi climat
je pense que le chiffre d'affaires des
éditeurs ne fera que croître dans les
années qui viennent et des avocats et
des cabinets
très bien merci monsieur le vice
président alors je vais vous proposer
parce que le sujet de la ruralité a été
traité plusieurs fois pendant les deux
premières tables rondes dont pour pas
faire de re dit je vais vous proposer de
passer directement aux questions et je
sais que le sujet de la ruralité va
faire l'objet de nombreuses questions de
la part de nos collègues donc je vais
passer la parole à mes collègues en
commençant par christian redon sarrazy
donc qui est sénateur qui siège à la
commission des affaires économiques et
qui est un des co auteurs du rapport sur
le zéro artificialisation note à lui
preuve des territoires cher christian si
tu veux bien poser des questions ensuite
jambes et oui merci madame la présidente
merci mesdames et messieurs pour vos
propos qui ne font que reprendre ce que
nous entendons régulièrement quand mes
collègues comme moi même parcours on a
nos territoires dans nos départements
donc lausanne vous l'avez rappelé est un
enjeux structurants pour nos territoires
qu'ils soient urbains ou ruraux et
j'insiste bien n'opposons pas les deux
sa déclinaison elle doit prendre en
compte et dynamique démographique
l'attractivité de nos territoires mais
aussi vous l'avez rappelé les défendre
les efforts qui sont déjà engagés et ça
a été signalé tout à l'heure par par
madame la vice présidente il implique
donc des changements importants des
modèles de vie des ruptures complète
et mais nécessite inéluctablement
l'adhésion des populations
donc sa première étape de mise en oeuvre
est aujourd'hui essentiel donc au delà
de la question de l'adaptation des
documents de planification et du
calendrier
imposé par l'exécutif qu'en dit que nous
avions dénoncée lors de l'examen de la
loi climat l'enjeu c'est bien
l'acceptabilité du projet dans la
dimension sociale et citoyenne et nous
devons sans arrêt le rappeler donc sans
cette adhésion collective qui permettra
en effet de construire des bases solides
de cette évolution profonde dont
l'objectif n'est pas remise en question
vous l'avez tous rappelé je me permets
ici de rappeler les trois mots clés de
la conclusion du rapport que vous
n'étiez un magma présidente et que
j'avais produit avec jean baptiste blanc
et anne catherine loisier c'était
territorialisée articulé et accompagner
donc l'objectif du zen doit être
l'occasion de nous amener à une
réflexion sur notre rapport à la ville
laisse sur notre rapport au territoire
l'occasion aussi de donner à tous les
habitants et aux élus du terrain des
perspectives nouvelles et innovantes de
développement
donc aussi avec mon groupe et j'en
profite pour rappeler malgré tout le
groupe socialiste n'avait pas approuvé
les conclusions de la cmp
en raison notamment des points que je
viens d'évoquer nous avons appelé le
gouvernement à revoir la méthode pour
une mise en oeuvre concertée
opérationnelle du than avec une
visibilité sur les financements
mobilisables et une mise en cohérence
avec d'autres politiques locales qu'il
s'agisse donc des politiques de
l'habitat des politique de
relocalisation ou des politiques donc de
développement industriel donc pour pour
aborder quelques points peut-être qu'ils
peuvent nous donner une perspective pour
gérer l'après
loi climat donc quelqu'un l'outil
prioritaires d'ingénierie au delà des
huit existants que vous avez évoquées ou
de ceux qui émergent
souhaiteriez-vous vers mise en oeuvre
pour pourra pour ces mesures
d'accompagnement quelles stratégies
proposées
pourraient être proposées pour assurer d
équilibre entre les territoires et créer
des dynamiques de projets de
développement qui soit à la fois durable
et social
pensez vous que des dispositifs et c'est
un sujet central que des dispositifs
spécifiques pourrait permettre à des
territoires très ruraux de sortir du
dispositif août - de l'aménager de
manière substantielle pour éviter le
blocage que l'on que l'on reconnaît que
l'on perçoit tous aujourd'hui de la part
notamment des très petites communes avec
des droits à construire quasiment
inexistant qui provoque chez les élus et
le président des maires ruraux l'a
rappelé une véritable fronde à faire
aujourd'hui c'est une incompréhension
même si il est probable que le nombre de
permis de construire sera très faible
dans certaines communes ça se compte sur
les doigts d'une main à peine mais mais
le fait de le fait de pour ces élus de
percevoir qu'ils n'auront pas de droit
c'est pour eux c'est un problème et
enfin pensez vous que cette échéance
2030 reste soutenable en l'état
merci beaucoup je peux être prendre les
3/4 première question est comme ça je
vous proposerai de répondre jean
baptiste blanc qui a été notre
rapporteur likely maintenant auteur un
nouveau rapport à la commission des
finances
merci madame la présidente je voulais
aussi vous remercier pour cette réunion
de ce matin qui est absolument décisive
pour ce sujet deux années notamment dans
le cadre des calendriers qui s'imposent
à nos élus locaux je pense à vos droits
propositions qui doivent exercer avant
le 22 octobre et qui est un calendrier
assez intenable on comprend ce matin
comme merci infiniment chère sophy
d'avoir permis cette réunion et
finalement de poursuivre ce sujet qui
est peut-être des plus importants voire
le plus important à mon sens pour nos
territoires depuis fort longtemps c'est
une révolution à bas bruit qui
d'ailleurs n'est plus du tout à bas
bruit maintenant puisque les médias
commencent à s'en emparer et
effectivement il faut prendre maintenant
des décisions alors site ici à travers
votre entremise qui a été votée la
territorialisation c'est ici maintenant
qu'il faut là qu'il faut là permettre la
rendent possible en améliorant beaucoup
de choses je trouve assez
hallucinant qu'on se réjouisse
collectivement que le gouvernement
daigne se repencher sur les décrets
c'est après tout c'est bien la moindre
des choses que le pouvoir réglementaire
cesse d'empiéter sur le domaine de la
loi et que le pouvoir réglementaire
finalement reviennent ce que nous avons
noté mais bon si dany le faire soit mais
c'est la moindre des choses après il
nous appartient collectivement de voir
ce que ce que nous devons faire alors il
ya plusieurs approches qui sont
possibles il ya demandé des dérogations
supplémentaires et puis il ya peut-être
contractualiser l'objectif et la
contractualisation c'est peut-être la
voie qu'il faut privilégier puisque
c'est la suite de l'histoire c'est la
suite de la territorialisation et puis
évidemment il ya les moyens donc est-ce
qu'il faut plus dérogation ce qu'il faut
des contrats ce qu'il faut plus de temps
et quel type de moyens alors les moyens
construit son
de partir parce qu'une commission des
finances en même temps mais c'est aussi
un sujet qu'on est là qu'on a mis sur la
table et on attend les conclusions du
conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
près la cour des comptes c'est une copie
qui doit être rendu au mois d'octobre
donc c'est un sujet qui n'a pas fini de
revenir non je pense qu'on partagera
collectivement les conclusions du cepeo
sur le sujet et les je voudrais réjouit
que les pistes ce matin
[Musique]
évoqués soit celle étudiée par le cepeo
la taxe d'aménagement notamment s'agit
pas de créer un impôt âmes est bien
d'accord mais bel et bien de réaménager
une fiscalité nationale et locale à
l'aune de ces nos objectifs climatiques
c'est aussi le grand moment ce qui
évidemment a des conséquences sur le
foncier qui est toujours plus rares et
donc toujours plus cher et nos élus nous
attendons aussi sur cet accompagnement
financier la voilà alors leur je retiens
là je vois là dans ce prénom ce matin un
encouragement à ce que finalement en
avant sur le sujet de la
contractualisation qui nous permettrait
peut-être de différencier et de tenir
compte des situations des territoires au
cas par cas en ce sens que l'objectif de
-50 % appliquée de manière uniforme
c'est particulièrement intenable
christian dont ça rase il l'a dit et
redit
avec qui on a rédigé ce premier rapport
d'où tout est parti voilà donc nos
objectifs intenables un objectif qu'on
ne peut appliquer impunément de manière
uniforme sur tout le territoire et peut
être une différence différenciation que
l'on pourrait atteindre par le contrat
avec un financement attachés et est-ce
qu'il faut
relier à ça
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on se donne comme
objectif d'obtenir plus de temps
sans doute mais si nous voulons obtenir
plus de temps il faut qu'on aille très
vite
là aussi puisque ça n'est que par la loi
que ça peut se faire on a obtenu
souvenez-vous six mois supplémentaires
à travers la loi cap bep ou 3ds d'où ce
22 octobre au lieu de
22 février mais cela nos acteurs est
vraiment intenable pour beaucoup de nos
territoires qui n'ont pas les mêmes
moyens d'ingénierie partout on l'a dit
et redit donc effectivement je m'associe
là aussi à toutes vos réflexions qui
déplore l'absence d'outils l'absence
d'ingénierie est elle nécessaire et
c'est nécessaire outil
le plus vite possible avec évidemment
une définition la plus claire possible
ce qui n'est toujours pas le cas voilà
oui et je clos en disant qu'il faut
aller vite
merci de remettre ces seuils de pouvoir
laisser la parole à tout le monde jean
claude anglars sénateur de l'aveyron
hauteur de proposition de loi
dérogatoire sont les zones rurales merci
madame la présidente et merci de
l'initiative à voir nous avons réuni et
d'avoir écouté les rues et représentants
des différentes institutions
en tout cas je vois que nous allons tous
dans le même sens alors moi j'ai commis
une proposition de loi le 14 décembre
2021 avec un constat simple comment nous
allons pouvoir arbitrer la question qui
nous est posée en train communes saint
chély d'aubrac sur l'aubrac les spas et
l'agglomération de toulouse comment cela
va finir je vous le pose comme ça en
tout cas posé ramener au terrain
effectivement on voit que ça paraissait
ubuesque et c'est toujours blessé donc
voila mon pas proposition de loi se
fonde sur un sujet de la densité de
population et communes peu denses ou
très peu denses donc 90% des communes en
france sont situés dans ces critères là
je rajoute un élément de ma proposition
de loi qu'il ya les territoires où déjà
la consommation d'espacé totalement
réduite je pense en particulier aux
communes qui sont qui obéissent à la
montagne par exemple où effectivement le
développement de l'urbanisation était
contré voilà donc c'était le sens de la
loi de ma proposition de loi comment on
peut effectivement trouver un critère de
différenciation autour de la densité de
population est un critère objectif de
l'insee est alors j'aimerais avoir votre
avis sur ce truc est sûre la sachant que
je rejoins ce qui a été dit sur l'idée
de contractualisation qu'il faudra voir
maintenant je dis aussi mais c'est
intéressant vraiment autre question et
nous avions amené à ce moment-là
malavard gong et ministre n'est ce pas
du logement à saint-gilles aubrac en lui
posant la question comme je lé fais
comment l arbitre la commune de
saint-chély-d'aubrac vers habitants au
kilomètre carré et l'agglomération de
toulouse qui a besoin de cet homme
comment on fait comment le sras d'eps
arbitral à faire
merci beaucoup cher jean claude de ces
remarques de bon sens et qui pose
d'ailleurs la question je vais vous
donner la parole évidemment dans des
réponses assez courtes s'il vous plaît
mais documenté
sur peut-être quelque chose que nous
touchons du doigt ici entre dérogation
et
contractualisation peut-être qu'elle est
votre votre point de vue au travers de
ses différentes questions
monsieur le vice président la
contractualisation effectivement c'est
une nouvelle méthode de l'état de faire
passer ses
objectifs mais je me pose la question du
périmètre
est-ce que c'est sur le périmètre des
crt e s que c'est sur le périmètre des
scot sur le périmètre des paies lui
quand il existe quand ils reviennent
tout ça comment on contractualise et
comment on évite une france à deux
vitesses
une france contractuels et une france
solidaire donc l'outil peut être
intéressant mais ou bien est-ce que d'un
côté l'état contre accueilli sur le pays
et lui parce que ça s'est fait comme ça
et que le préfet dans un autre
département va dire je contractualise
sur le scot ou bien sûr et certain e s
que là on va avoir de la différenciation
des contractualisations s'aimer question
pourquoi pas à partir de nous ne
confondons pas la fin et les moyens si
le contrat est adaptée au territoire
c'est ça qui est intéressant plutôt que
de dire on fait des contrats sur les
scot point barre donc là aussi je pense
qu'il faudra aussi être très flexibles
par rapport à ça
peut-être aussi qu'il faut s'appuyer sur
l'année c'était
l'agent spécial de cohésion des
territoires c'est peut-être elle qui va
falloir utiliser un naturellement le
préfet le délit et territoriales mais
vers qui se tourner le préfet délégué
territorial de l'ars été lorsqu'il a un
questionnement l'un de ces cellules
robin vers la ddt voilà parce qu'il n'ya
pas d'ingénierie supplémentaire donc
tout comme l'état a commencé une phase
de
et métropolisation ses services centraux
avec notamment les services de bercy est
ce qu'on pourrait pas aussi envisager de
la dea métropolisation du ministère de
l'équipement pour renvoyer les
ingénieurs cher à 10 présidente sur les
territoires il ya aussi ce sujet-là de
de déconcentration des effectifs de la
fonction publique d'état pour
ré alimenter nos fameuses nos fameuses
dde et puis se trouve que je siège aussi
au cpe donc on a commencé les travaux
j'ai eu une séance de travail de deux
heures avec les administrateurs de la
cour des comptes sur le sujet et
je pense qu'on aura on on essaiera de
vous donner une expertise sur le sujet
mais on pense aussi que la taxe
d'aménagement reste quand même le
vecteur le plus efficace pour alimenter
les surcoûts nécessaires à la réfection
des friches qu'elle soit d'habitat ou
l'économie n'oublions pas que
réhabiliter une friche économique ces
cinq à sept fois plus cher qu'à aménager
un terrain agricole dans une activité
très bien y at il d'autres demandes de
prise de parole madame laigneau oui nous
tenir ce que de ce que j'ai dit mais je
sue serait tout à faire de ce qui a été
évoqué par jean baptiste blanc pour ce
qui concerne à la contractualisation
alors
j'entends les difficultés qu'il ya dans
les périmètres mais cette
contractualisation elle a des vertus
parce qu'elle permet d'abord de tenir
compte du territoire donc c'est pas un
déchet c'est pas un défaut seulement de
l'état c'est l'état c'est un
accompagnement de l'état auprès des
collectivités
contractualisation d'être que j'aperçois
c'est plus un accompagnement de l'état à
la méthode et à
comment dire l'objectif est toujours le
même l'objectif est toujours le même
mais la façon d'y parvenir peut être
différente selon les territoires parce
que les territoires ont des ont des
problèmes différents et je souhaiterais
insister aussi sur la temporalité moi je
pense que là le délai qui est un parti
est très court il ya tellement
d'inconnues tellement de confusion donc
sur tous les sujets comment les vite
avec dédé des questionnements aussi
aussi important sur tous les sujets
alors je peux les listes et il y à des
confusions la loi introduit ces
confusions et donc il faudrait
effectivement un peu de temps pour ne
serait-ce que bien calé ce que nous
devons faire comment nous devons le
faire les objectifs les objectifs
poursuivis les modalités de poursuite de
ses objectifs est alors par la
contractualisation et ce qui permettrait
de travailler correctement parce que
actuellement nous sommes dans totalement
dans le flou aller vite dans le flou
c'est compliqué quand même donc enfin je
voudrais insister là dessus merci
monsieur gouttebel peut-être oui madame
la présidente
effectivement et je souhaitais aborder
aussi dans le tout ce qui réussit plage
du foncier notamment territoire rural on
a aussi des friches agricoles on a aussi
malheureusement un peu plus importante
la plus importante
des locaux commerciaux qui sont passés
aux blancs et qui malheureusement les
gens sont partis derrière tout ça il
faut qu'ils se prévoit aussi des
facilités aux changements de destination
parce que vous savez tous quand on a
bien fait nos documents d'urbanisme
certains locaux sont fléchés en dix ans
et or ont changé de destination
et quand c'est pas possible revoir
l'intégralité du règlement à des choses
de ce type là c'est totalement
contre-productif aussi sur le fait de
pouvoir rénover le bâti déjà présents
donc ça veut dire dans le même temps
aussi revoir une partie du code du
patrimoine
on a la chance effectivement d'avoir un
patrimoine terrible fort riche
exceptionnelle en france mais nos
interactions avec les dracs nous
contraignent aussi dans la rénovation du
bâti ancien et là aussi je pense qu'il
ya quelque chose à travailler à revoir
sur cette partie là les maires héros
tout de suite travail sur la notion de
village d'avenir qui pourrait être le
pendre ou l'apport ou la continuité de
petites villes de demain de coeur de
ville pour les villes moyennes et à six
de suite derrière cuissard
se pose effectivement la question de
l'équilibré je crois que vous l'avez si
effectivement la notion d' équilibre
territorial du droit la différenciation
et il faut absolument que tous ces
futurs éléments alors quand on parle de
contractualisation il faut aussi être
prudent puisque derrière ça veut dire
que ça sous-entend des moyens mais les
moyens ça peut être justement des droits
à construire des droits au projet et
instanciés critère de différenciation
c'est justement se rappeler
collectivement que c'est des outils au
service du projet des territoires à des
projets des territoires donc j'ai été
ravi dans le temps que laïcité devenait
ce qu'on péter parce qu'effectivement ça
reste tout de suite une belle coquille
vide
entendent avoir entendu parler ce matin
deux des deux m'a rappelé ma jeunesse
mais derrière tout ça c'est aussi vous
l'avez tous 10 sénateurs et vous
représentants d'associations d'élus le
monde a généré dans nos territoires
ruraux qui pour répondre aux
sollicitations dans les délais
contraints tout de suite en frôle
impossible au vu de ce qu'on vient de
vivre depuis deux ans pour rentrer dans
le cadre des crt le genre des plans de
relance et ainsi de suite nos personnels
sont aussi à bout il faut l'entendre il
faut le dire on aura du mal à suivre
clairement que ce soit les élus mais
aussi nos collaborateurs donc derrière
tout ça quant à la conclusion est de
continuer localement on appuie savoir
libre administration de nos territoires
et de nos communes ce soit
l'intercommunalité et d'éviter cette
mise en tout elle cette mise sous
tutelle qui parfois devient systématique
dès qu'on lève le doigt pour vouloir
faire quelque chose merci madame la
présidente le merci pour cette native
merci monsieur miossec
merci de me permettre de rebondir aussi
sur les éléments les questions de locaux
l'ex-sénateur
diamant en fait en écoutant les uns les
autres comme on a dit qu'on était tous
d'accord sur le l'objectif et l'ambition
la question se concentre essentiellement
sur les moyens parler des moyens
financiers ils sont ils sont vraiment à
questionner les moyens d'ingénierie sont
aussi au coeur de la réponse et je juge
nous mettre parfois devant nos propres
contradictions collective on réclame de
la contractualisation et de l'autonomie
et en même temps on a fait l'éloge de la
vidéo les uns et les autres
non c'est ce que je vais dire je peux je
dirais je pourrais dire elle moi même là
la même chose mais attention à pour moi
la meilleur générique c'est quand même
celle qu'on peut avoir à notre propre
disposition dans nos territoires donc ça
passe par le renforcement des moyens
d'ingénierie sur ces questions là dans
nos territoires donc les communes quand
elles ont la capacité à le faire mais le
plus souvent c'est à l'échelle
intercommunale pour pouvoir l'autonomie
de mener à bien nos projets territoire
de dépenses et de les appréhender dans
toute la complexité que ça pose mais
pour pouvoir avoir les moyens dans nos
propres
intercommunalités ou d'eau propre
territoire ça pose la question de moyens
financiers qui sont qui sont de plus en
plus contraints évidemment et puis ça
pose la question que plusieurs ont
évoqué de la sécurité juridique
moi je suis un père fervent
décentralisateur mais il faut aussi
qu'on puisse être sécurisés dans l'eau
dans nos responsabilités locales et la
bord est un document d'urbanisme
je suis maire de commune de 4000
habitants depuis 14 ans j'ai élaboré un
élu à l'échelle communale et j'en
termine un à l'échelle intercommunale en
tant que président de l'intercommunalité
à chaque fois ces exercices ça a été
évoqué par les uns les autres et les
ondes de toulouse tout à l'heure mais
ces exercices qui gérait coûte de
l'argent et qui juridiquement sont
souvent fragiles donc on a besoin de
sécuriser ces documents et dale
parlement évidemment un rôle à jouer et
de garder de la souplesse aussi parce
qu'on voit les délais que ça peut
prendre
parce qu'on a complexifié beaucoup de
choses donc plaidoyer pour la
responsabilité locale plaidoyer pour le
pmu et le pmu intercommunale
mais mais mais peu importe qu'ils soient
communales ou intercommunales c'est
d'abord que nous élus locaux on s'empare
de ces de ces outils pour penser le
développement de nos territoires et
penser aussi des solidarités
territoriales et je crois que le père
lui et est un outil justement une forme
de contractualisation entre nous de se
mettre d'accord entre élus des communes
de même intercommunalité sur le projet
de territoire et sa façon petit se
traduit en termes urbain donc
peu près la moitié des intercommunalités
de france aujourd'hui ont pris la
compétence père et lui sont en cours
d'élaboration de leurs documents
d'autres début de ce mandat même si le
mandat a été le début de mandat a été
particulièrement impacté par la par la
crise sanitaire mais d'autres
collectivités à l'intercommunalité en
france se sont intéressés au sujet et
lui et je pense que ça peut être un
outil quand même malgré sa complexité
c'est un outil qui peut permettre de
bien penser la solidarité urbaine rurale
à l'échelle du bassin de vie
avec un outil est lui qui est qu'on
veuille ou non protège quand même plutôt
les communes rurales puisque les
modalités d'adoption des pmu
intercommunaux font que les conseils
municipaux et les élus communaux des
communales dans les conseils
communautaires ont une
voir importantes qui les protège même si
je n'ignore pas que beaucoup de
territoires sont encore
craintifs à s'engager dans lequel
intercommunale vu la lourdeur et la
difficulté de l'outil mais je crois que
c'est vraiment une une
opportunité lausanne de se redire
prenons en main dans nos territoires là
les politiques d'urbanisation à travers
des outils notamment gars merci beaucoup
monsieur me siècle alors je vais donner
la parole à mes collègues de la
commission qui sont enfin ceux qui sont
présents
g8 demande de parole dont je vous
demande vraiment à leurs neuf je vous
demande d'être extrêmement concis
vraiment de ne pas être redondant s'il
vous plaît dans les questions que vous
posez et surtout de nommer l'association
à laquelle vous posez la question parce
que ça voilà ça permettra d'être
efficace sachant qu'il nous reste au
grand maximum une demi heure car nous
avons une obligation sur les amendements
pour la loi pouvoir d'achat donc je suis
désolé pour les contraintes de tout le
monde mais on va essayer d'être rapide
jean marc boyer ensuite france photo g
oui merci madame la présidente pour
l'organisation de cette rencontre ce
matin et
je vous dirais franchement que je suis
surpris voire
déçu de certaines propositions qui sont
faites en particulier au niveau en tant
que l'association des maires qui
représente donc les maires
nous ici au sénat nous représentons les
territoires nous entendons des
territoires ruraux nous représentons
d'habitants ruraux et l'ensemble des
communes de notre de nos départements
mais je crois aujourd'hui que
[Musique]
il ya un élément qui est oublié
c'est le maire de la commune et le maire
de la commune
on a un groupe de travail qui a été
constituée au niveau de notre formation
politique au niveau du scénario du
groupe des républicains qui regroupe une
centaine de sénateurs et les conclusions
de ses travaux c'était de redonner au
maire la maîtrise de leur développement
redonné au maire la maîtrise de leur
développement parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
des mères qui se sentent complètement
déshabillés de leurs compétences
l'intercommunalité a pris l'ensemble des
compétences économiques
touristiques etc etc et finalement si on
enlève complètement la compétence
concernant l'urbanisme il ne va pas leur
rester grand chose autrement dit il ne
restera rien du tout donc je pense que
aujourd'hui il ya deux constat que l'on
fait 10 % des communes en particulier de
métropole hors jeu ne peuvent pas fait
comment tu veux dire comme tout le monde
doit pas faire l'opposition d'urbain du
rural mais finalement lorsqu'on arrive
aux conclusions on en arrive un peu à ça
on va pas faut pas être hypocrite non
plus 10 % des communes en particulier de
métropole sont responsables de 71%
d'artifice de l'artificialisation des
sols au niveau national 10 %
aujourd'hui l'épée élus des communes
rurales sont amputés de 60 % de leur
surface constructible et ça c'est dû à
quoi c'est dû au vote je suis désolé moi
je le vis comme ça dans mon département
donc l'objectif aujourd'hui il me semble
c'est de rééquilibrer les rapports
entre les communes les intercommunalités
et de et de données de permettre et
d'innover en matière d'urbanisme alors
permettre aux maires de s'opposer à une
diminution de leurs droits à construire
et même je dirais aller plus loin les
données leur donner la possibilité de
majorer des possibilités de construction
aux communes et non seulement et pas
seulement aux pc donc moi j'étais un
petit peu je dirais le choc et ce matin
d'entendre certaines chose qui vraiment
me gêne on a des points importants qui
ont été avancées au niveau de notre
groupe d'autres par exemple c'est
d'autoriser des constructions
nécessaires l'equilibre des
exploitations agricoles c'est de donner
une nouvelle définition du hameau le
hameau en zone de montagne en zone
rurale c'est une structure importante
qui aujourd'hui d'administration nommés
en opposition la notion de hameaux pour
des refus de permis de construire
renforcée des droits de préemption des
communes enfin bref alors c'est vrai
qu'il faut thériault territorialisée
différencier dans l'application des
règles bien sûr mais je pense que vous
avez posé la question la limite c'est
c'est quelle est la limite des
territoires ou à pouvoir effectivement
territorialisées c'est là où on voir les
vraies difficultés donc redonnant du
pouvoir de décision aux maires de
communes merci jean marc redonner la au
maire la maîtrise de leur développement
ce sera une question composera à la mf
on l'a compris je passe la parole à
franck montaugé ensuite jean claude
tissot merci madame la présidente merci
à vous tous pour vous et vos expressions
vos propositions qui enrichissent notre
réflexion partir de le moment moi je
veux on l'a constaté on est d'accord sur
l'objectif du design en lui même la
question qui se pose à nous elle est
celle de la méthode du commun donc moi
je voudrais en quelques mots vous faire
partager l'expérience de mon département
j'ai contribué à la au lancement mais à
l'émergence d'un scot très rurale quasi
départementale c'est le plus grand de
france qui s'appelle le scope de
gascogne et dancette
ce développement dans ce développement
on à catégoriser les communes r d plus
rurales et il y en a de très très rurale
dans mon département jusqu'à la cheffe
de département qui est une agglomération
mais une ville moyenne et c'est à partir
de ces de ces classes de communes qu'on
était
pris en compte les potentiels d'accueil
et la manière dont peut se répartir
peuvent se répartir les autorisations
les autorisations de darty fille
d'artificialisation des sols je rajoute
à ça que pour certaines communes qui
n'ont pas eu les moyens de se payer un
pays ou de rentrer dans une démarche de
paix lui intercommunale il est
nécessaire je rejoins en cela certaines
expressions qu'on puisse adapter à la
marge le rn eu ça c'est absolument
absolument nécessaire et se renvoient à
la remarque que faisait christian sur le
fait christian où
jean baptiste
relatif à l'accueil de quelques voix là
de quelques de quelques maisons sûres
sur un territoire donné je termine en
disant que cette méthodologie il faut la
sortir de contractualisation et je
regrette que que l'amendement que nous
avions proposé lors de la discussion de
la loi climat résilience n'était même
pas été retenu par la majorité parce
qu'il était exactement en rapport avec
la nécessité effectivement de
contractualiser avec les maires et les
présidents
d'intercommunalités communalité
concernés voilà donc pour ceux que ça
intéresserait je vous mettrais un
rapport le président du scot de gascogne
voilà qui développe une méthode très
intéressante qui va pas résoudre tous
les problèmes mais qui est quand même
très structuré et qui permet de faire
des choses je dirais on l'a
compréhensible équitable merci france
pour cette prise de parole qui est plus
une position qu une question si je
comprends bien jean petit s'offre oui
merci madame la présidente je vais
essayer de faire aussi court que notre
collègue boyer suite évident
au regard des dérives constatées dans
les précédentes décennies il était
certes indispensables on l'a dit à
différentes repris ce matin de se fixer
enfin un cap de sobriété consommation de
l'espace mais la mise en oeuvre de
l'objectif
anne ne doit pas se traduire par une
condamnation pure et simple de la
vitalité de nos communes rurales celle
ci passe en effet nous le savons tous
par des possibilités de développement
même mesuré qui garantisse par exemple
renouvellement des effectifs de nos
écoles ou développement certes modeste
au 6 mai du développement économique
avec des pics d'activités artisanales et
c'est aussi à mon sens il va falloir
ajuster la déclination du zen dans nos
territoires pour corriger certains
effets indésirables qui n'ont pas été
assez anticipées je pense notamment à
cette sorte d'effet cocktail issue
d'articulation du zen avec les autres
documents d'urbanisme plu scot sera
nette sans parler des pluies à venir il
faudrait revoir l'échelle de répartition
des droits à construire il n'est pas
souhaitable pour l'équilibré du
territoire qu une approche régionale
réserve au sol ville déjà attractive par
exemple pour ma région annecy ou lyon
l'essentiel des droits à construire
tandis que les communes rurales se
retrouve avec zéro possibilités et de
même il est regrettable que les
municipalités qui ont été des plus
vertueuses dans le passé se voient
pénalisés aujourd'hui parce qu'elles
n'ont pas attendu l'objectif vannes pour
essayer de maîtriser leur consommation
des espaces enfin la définition même de
ce qu'est l'artificialisation aime
parfois à mon sens mal adapté c'est
ainsi le cas de certaines dents creuses
dans nos villages qui avaient certes
autrefois une destination agricole qui
sont définitivement plus cultivables
parce qu'on peut plus faire entre un
tracteur ou en raison des distances
d'épandage par exemple il faudrait
permettre que de tels terrains qu'ils
soient parfois de véritables qui sont
maintenant
parfois de véritables friche puisse
devenir constructibles la question que
je pose est finalement très simple on
l'a déjà dit à différentes reprises mme
comment prendre en compte ces réalités
sans renoncer à un objectif global de
préservation des terres agricoles et
naturels je vous remercie merci jean
claude et vine renault garabédian
merci la dentelle nous avons abordé
aujourd'hui cette table ronde sur un
aspect très technique moi j'aimerais
bien revenir avec vous sur des retours
d'expérience par rapport à une situation
aujourd'hui qui est particulièrement
urgente les entreprises elles sont à
citer aujourd'hui à se déplacer des
centres villes pour aller dans les
périphériques ville pour des raisons
financières puisque le prix au mètre
carré du foncier est beaucoup moins
important et également pour la fiscalité
locale est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faudrait une intervention nationale pour
modifier cet état de fait notamment sur
le problème de la fiscalité la tombe la
pandémie que nous avons vécu ces deux
dernières années a eu pour effet de
de rendre des bureaux disponibles en
centre ville notamment à cause de du
développement du télétravail qui a eu
lieu ces derniers temps il s'agit
sûrement d'une occasion de ce qui est à
saisir pour freiner l'artificialisation
des sols j'aimerais avoir un petit peu
vous réflexion à ce sujet merci
ghislaine à celui à celui où de
l'association des maires de france ou
bien à 100 sur ben police urbaine peut
être très bien merci evelyne guilhem
pantel ensuite rémy chardon merci madame
la présidente les communes rurales ont
une vive inquiétude quant à leur main
que de compétences techniques en interne
bien sûr et pour pour anticiper un plan
d'aménagement contenant l'objectif de
zéro artificialisation net ont-elles des
ressources disponibles pour s'offrir la
possibilité de faire intervenir un
cabinet privé un organisme privé
extérieur en guise d'appui technique
comment la puissance publique peut-elle
le palier à ce manque de moyens vient
peut-être un renforcement des services
de la ddt
et ne nous y revoilà et ensuite la
flexibilité sur la contractualisation
que propose monsieur alain chrétien ne
risque-t-elle pas de susciter des
inégalités entre les territoires c'est à
dire entre les métropoles qui ont des
services fournis et les cons comme rural
qui dont les services se sont bien plus
modestes et pour que cette
contractualisation soit qualitative ça
nécessite évidemment des moyens humains
merci
ghislaine offrait un propos liminaire
général rémi cardon suite laurent saumon
merci me disant tu les messieurs les
représentants des élus d'associations
d'élus chers collègues moi j'aimerais
effectivement posées aux débats
plusieurs réflexions et une questions
assez précises déjà sur la mise en
application de la zone pose
effectivement la question du comment ça
a été dit par plusieurs de mes collègues
l'objectif on il est plutôt clair mais
encore faut-il effectivement être à la
hauteur des enjeux etc j'ai un peu du
mal a effectivement comme vous chers
collègues à à comprendre comment on peut
donner un objectif
avoir réfléchi à réellement la méthode
et comment et le mettre en place c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense que
les corps intermédiaires que vous êtes
les en tant qu association qui
représente les collectivités
ce qui serait pas temps effectivement de
vous collectivement avec des
parlementaires de d'imposer au
gouvernement une méthode et ça peut se
combler sur plusieurs propositions parce
que j'identifie effectivement plusieurs
problèmes
notamment ça a été dit par monsieur
chrétien de la mf sur le le manque de
documents d'urbanisme dans 30% dans nos
collectivités cela a été aussi relevée
par plusieurs de mes collègues il est
comment la vie nécessaire aujourd'hui on
a effectivement des des agents de la dg
philippe qui accompagnent les décideurs
sur les problématiques budgétaires
est-ce qu'il faut effectivement des des
agents de la société ou autres qui
viennent accompagner nos mers parce que
ça a été dit par mme a calé juste avant
effectivement la difficulté de se payer
un cabinet de conseil ou d'avocats pose
quand même problème notamment sur des
petites collectivités ensuite sur les
réunions de concertation je pense que le
problème il faut le voir au niveau
départemental et évacuer le niveau
régional parce que sinon on va perdre du
temps je déjà sur le la problématique
notamment sur un sujet que vous
connaissez tous a été soulevée par la
présidence et ce sera certainement sauvé
par mon collègue laurent saumon le canal
seine-nord la répartition suite à des
gros projets à dimension nationale ou
européenne
comment la répartition des quotas sera
fait est ce qu'on sera pénalisé tout ça
reste encore peu claires
c'est la raison pour laquelle il va
falloir mettre ça sur les retards assez
rapidement et enfin je terminerai sur
une proposition sur les réunions de
concertation départementale porté par
les associations d'élus et
parlementaires ou autre
il serait peut-être intéressant d'être
capable de chiffrer les besoins en fonds
friche
par département et de voir comment le
gouvernement peut y répondre alors je
dis pas qu'il pourra répondre à la
totalité des besoins mais au moins qu'on
fasse les choses à l'envers cette fois
ci c'est tout on a toujours tendance de
faire le de balancer des budgets des
crédits et ensuite de voir comment on va
le répartir un peu à l'arraché excusez
moi du terme mais c'est souvent comme ça
merci rémi laurent saumon en visio
ensuite henri cabanel et martin berthet
et bonjour à toutes et à tous merci pour
cette conférence je vais aller droit au
but à première question qui était déjà
posée par amy quart d'once effectivement
comment des comptes les projets
nationaux et régionaux d'intérêt
régionaux et nationaux je pense bien sûr
au canal seine nord europe mais aussi
aux plateformes portuaires inhérentes à
ce projet premier point commun que l'on
fait deuxième point va t-on à imposer la
réduction des consommations sens hier
des énergies renouvelables la même
manière qu'on le fait pour la
consommation pour les logements sachant
que le département de la somme est le
premier département qui voit émerger des
éoliennes et la carte des échos qui
vient récemment d'être encore sorti pour
juillet 2022 le prouve et ne devrait-on
pas pour autant aussi obligé de dire et
les projets par exemple les surfaces
commerciales sur les zones inerte en
particulier les toitures ou les parkings
à développer des énergies renouvelables
qui éviterait la consommation foncière
par ailleurs le point principal c'était
très simple c'est n'est-il pas
nécessaire de préciser les c'est de la
sémantique dans les textes
réglementaires pour éviter des
contentieux souvent d'interprétation
j'en cite deux mais je crois que c'était
déjà posées notamment par
monsieur tissot c'est la terre la terre
agricole en zone urbaine qu'est ce que
c'est et qu'est ce qu'une dent creuse
parce qu'aujourd'hui souvent rétorque au
maire et au projet de permis de
construire que la dent creuse est trop
petit ou trop longues ou trop trop
grande ou trop ou trop éloignés comme
des amoureux qui a évoqué jean marc
boyer ça dépend des cas une dent creuse
ne doit-on pas véritable et il ya
beaucoup de mâchoire aussi surtout dans
certaines ddtm il ya beaucoup de
mâchoire et enfin ne serait-il pas
judicieux de simplifier on parle
toujours simplification à force de
diviser par l'avis d'une commission
sites et paysages de la bf la cdp naf et
bien d'arriver finalement qu on
aboutisse pas et j'ai fait une
proposition département de la somme pour
laurent parce qu'il nous révèle un quart
d'heure pour tous répondre est-ce qu'on
peut ne pas faire plus simple trois
personnes soit 3 personnes ou trois
représentants préfet chambre
d'agriculture et le maire de la commune
qui doivent pouvoir trouver sur des sur
des demandes d'aidé des solutions
adéquates et puis enfin dernière fois ne
serait-il pas justement légitime d'avoir
un droit minimum à construire pour les
communes merci laurent parlant de vous
presser en relationnel merci même la
prison merci pour cette table ronde moi
je voudrais revenir un petit peu en
europe est élu et éventuellement que lui
comment se fait-il et on ne peut pas
parler d'eux annecy ap ap lui paie lui
il me semble comment se fait-il que
depuis 2000 que on peut mettre en place
donc après la loi sru les plan local
d'urbanisme comment se fait-il qu'il y
encore autant de communes qui n'est pas
eu de pluie alors jeune tonnes sur l'
écoute mais depuis 2014 et la
possibilité de faire payer hui et on ne
peut pas ne pas avoir cette volonté au
niveau communal de pouvoir voir en plat
local unique comment se fait-il que on
épand depuis 112 ans 22 ans après avoir
encore autant de communes sempé lui ou
paix lui et haut niveau donc donc de la
répartition on sait très bien que cette
loi va pénaliser l'hébreu élèves est-ce
que vous avez donc et j'entends qu'il ne
faut pas opposer
l'urbain les territoires urbains et les
territoires ruraux mais on sait très
bien que c'est le pot de fer contre le
pot de terre et comment envisagez-vous
justement le fait qu' il y est des
territoires qu'ils aient abusé de
l'artificialisation et d'autres qui est
joué le jeu comment envisagez-vous donc
cette répartition sans pouvoir opposer
les territoires urbains aux territoires
ruraux merci dernière question qu'elle
m'a promise rapide martin berthet oui
merci madame la présidente je vais
essayer de faire très vite donc
effectivement c'est un sujet qui
questionnent beaucoup nos mères dans les
départements et pourtant les préfets des
services de l'état de façon générale au
niveau départemental
semble être complètement démuni sur ce
sujet alors qu'il devrait être là en
soutien donc s proprement département où
s
général j'aimerais revenir aussi sur la
question des grands chantiers alors je
pense au lyon turin par exemple des
grands chantiers qui vont être impactés
au niveau régional mais je pense qu'il
devrait être complètement sorti même du
paquet régionales il n'y a que madame
l'agneau de france urbaine vient à
parler j'aimerais avoir l'avis des
autres associations et puis la dernière
chose un retour donc sur les coûts des
terrains en zone touristique de montagne
et l'inquiétude qui augmente de façon
exponentielle qui existait déjà mais qui
existe qui augmente vraiment de façon
exponentielle de la part de nos mères de
voir les villages se vident et parce que
nos jeunes ne pourront plus rester
habiter au pays donc là c'était un
retour important et j'aimerais avoir
votre avis en montagne et je me permets
de rajouter littoral probablement
braqués sur toutes les zones
touristiques très bien merci chers
collègues je vais donc vous redonner la
parole à tous les quatre parce que voilà
vous avez été sollicité à tour de rôle
on va recommencer par monsieur chrétien
monsieur vice président merci même
présidente je vais répondre
conjointement aux sénateurs boyer et
cabanel parce que leurs questions se se
rejoignent un peu alors pardon aux
sénateurs boyer si on a pu le choquer
mais la mfc la mf l'association des
maires de france et nous sommes là pour
défendre le pouvoir des maires la
souveraineté municipal dans le cadre
républicain
donc on ne peut pas faire fi des
problématiques intercommunale puisque
par définition une commune et voisine
d'une autre commune etc etc donc il est
clair que nous sommes pour le pays et
lui avec la majorité à la minorité de
blocage qui a été instituée par la loi
je crois et c'est rue à quelques
élan aux allures je sais plus et qu'il
est hors de question d'obliger
les maires à déléguer leur pouvoir
d'urbanisme à l'intercommunalité
position la nfl est claire elle changera
pas
mais j'irai plus loin c'est que la
trentaine de pour cent de communes
rurales qui sont opérés nues elles n'ont
déjà plus le pouvaient ils n'ont jamais
eu le pouvoir d'urbanisme puisque quand
il délivre un permis de temps en temps
ce nom de l'état c'est pas au nom de la
collectivité locale donc s'il ya bien un
moyen pour le maire de la commune rurale
de retrouver du pouvoir d'urbanisme
c'est de faire un peu et lui et que si
elle à 200 habitants show point ma la
mère de 200 habitants financer deux cent
mille euros 1 p lus pour sa commune de
200 habitants et l'intelligence
collective veux qu'on se réunisse autour
de la table de l'intercommunalité pour
se dire comment on reprend le pouvoir de
l'urbanisme dans nos territoires
jusqu'aujourd'hui on est en 1ère et nu
est le seul qui a le pouvoir d'urbanisme
dans nos territoires c'est l'état donc
pour moi le pnud est l'outil de reprise
en main par le maire de sa politique
d'urbanisme et que quand il fait 2 100
habitants le maire de la commune
pardon mais si le conseil municipal de
la commune accepte de dépenser 200 mille
euros pour faire 1 p lus sur la commune
de 200 habitants
c'est qu'il a beaucoup c'est qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'argent et tant mieux pour eux
ou que ils n'ont pas envie de travailler
avec les autres et c'est compliqué quand
on fait de l'aménagement du territoire
donc nous ne sommes pas des aficionados
dp lui ça doit être sur la volonté
communale la concertation communal est
effectivement comme le sénateur cabanel
je trouve encore surprenant qu'on ait
encore beaucoup de d'élus qui ne sentent
pas la nécessité de travailler ensemble
pour utiliser au mieux leur territoire
par le biais du pied lui qui n'est qu'un
outil c'est pas une fin en soi c'est un
outil et donc il faut qu'on continue le
travail de persuasion et de hêtres
pédagogie mais le meilleur moyen pour le
maire de garder sa politique cette créer
son propre document d'urbanisme et je
fais fi des cartes communales qui pour
le coup en termes depuis d'optimisation
financière il vaut mieux se payer un pl
tout de suite que de passer par la case
carte carte communale qui est un outil
qui est insuffisant sur beaucoup de
sujets
dernier point je vous rappelle que la
loi
permet aussi de garder la maîtrise de la
signature du permis de construire
il ya beaucoup d'intercommunalité que
mon équipe et lui mais qui ont décidé de
laisser aux mères le soin de signer leur
propre permis et parfois de refuser de
signer un permis et même si le service
instructeur
le lui lui soumet un avis positif donc
le maire in fine et reste maître de son
territoire parce que c'est lui qui signe
encore en conscience les propres laisser
permis de construire qui est
effectivement un des pouvoirs j'allais
dire régaliens du maire auquel il tient
et auquel il a raison de tenir voilà
deux signé les permis de construire je
fais court mais on pourrait y passer
beaucoup de temps
remercie monsieur gouttebel pour la
mairesse avait été à la solliciter
plusieurs fois
oui effectivement
je comprend effectivement que certaines
nos collègues n'est pas souhaité établir
des documents d'urbanisme de par les
enjeux de leur commune effectivement
mais c'est souvent lié aussi au coût
financier vous n'avez vit tous et
derrière à la grande complexité
administrative pour faire ce type de
document et en a aussi ça c'est vrai
qu'on a certainement territoire on a
évoqué deux montagnes qui ont peu de
projets de façon annuelle et il n'a pas
été trouvé cette logique effectivement
de rentrer dans cette démarche
effectivement d'établir des documents
mais vous l'avez tous dit effectivement
à bélus appelle une bille c'est la libre
administration d'un territoire c'est une
volonté des élus de s'organiser pour à
l'échelle de la commune ou à l'échelle
d'une intercommunalité ça pose la
question effectivement des effets
induits les plans locaux d'habitat
lescott et derrière ils en faire comme
il est toujours dans le détail d'autres
documents qui s'impose entre guillemets
au même peuple qui est en cours
d'élaboration ou en d'élaboration cette
complique et administratives
franchement a contraint certains de nos
collègues à ne pas se poser la question
et même à l'échelle d'une petite
intercommunalité quand elles sont deux
montagnes ce qui est le cas dans notre
territoire depuis deux hommes
au delà des coups c'est vrai que cette
complexité là est de se dire on s'engage
sur trois ans 57 ans a été un frein
aussi à la mise en place de ce type
d'outil donc penser ça il ya des choses
importantes effectivement la minorité de
blocage est une bonne chose pour
justement ne pas faire c'est quand même
important de le maintenir et de se dire
on peut discuter se rappeler que
derrière tout ça dans la vie plan
administration de nos territoires
jamar puisqu'on a le plaisir de se bien
connu de bien se connaître il faut que
la commune reste au sang au centre au
coeur des débats d'aquaman ce n'est pas
qu'à meyers un conseil municipal cd est
lui quasi bénévole qui mouillent la
chemise tous les jours au quotidien et
c'est presque 500 mille élus bénévoles
en france font quand même tourner la
machine depuis un bon moment
depuis deux ans je crois qu'il faut
justement le respectent et se dire que
il faut qu'on leur donne la main aussi
les soutenir dans leurs futurs projets
revenir très brièvement
sur la comptabilisation de ski et
régional ou national
effectivement quand on cite le
lyon-turin moi très inquiet sur des
déclinaisons sur l'imaginent qui a le
droit à 100 je sais pas combien prendra
le nom qu elle aussi prend 20 cents 500
des métropoles voilà sans sac à main et
ctc voilà c'est à peu près ça ça veut
dire que dans la déclinaison et pour que
ça arrive sur ma commune à murol
deux fois au tribunal administratif pour
recours donc je ne sais pas combien de
temps il va perdurer
ça veut dire qu'on risque d'avoir que
pour nos territoires ruraux et si ça
peut être ma conclusion il faut qu'on
reparte effectivement des territoires
pour faire remonter les projets merci à
tous merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président miossec à
merci davance de cet échange qui en
appellera sûrement de l'étendue des
questions pour répondre rapidement le
jeu noté 5.1 très court sur les grands
projets
c'est bien de le dire la question de la
part du gâteau entre guillemets qui est
prise par les grands projets à l'échelle
nationale ou régionale elle et elle est
crucial puisque puisque basse et c'est
vraiment ouhlala
l'impact en cascade sur les territoires
qui se pose pour autant que la
solidarité nationale
s'exprime quand il ya des grandes
infrastructures qui bénéficie à
l'ensemble du territoire c'est pas
illogique que ça se calcule à l'échelle
nationale mais tout le diable se cache
dans les détails
deuxième point sur la question des
bérets plusieurs plusieurs élus pierre
sénateurs ont posé des questions de 2,2
du calendrier
nos associations nombreuses ont exprimé
le souhait de pouvoir d'étendre ce
calendrier
pour autant même si l'inde d'octobre
était maintenu ça s'est passé pas la fin
de l'histoire le 22 octobre et je
fais comment dire mais la façon
d'appréhender le l'idée du zen c'est de
se dire en fait on a un gros coup de
frein
aujourd'hui une prise de conscience à
avoir sur la question du foncier et la
consommation foncière
mais mais forcément dans le temps on
aura besoin d'eux de souplesse donc se
dire d'ores et déjà que c'est impossible
à prendre en compte il faut tout de
suite se donner beaucoup plus de temps
je ne faut pas que ce soit
contradictoire avec le fait qu' il faut
qu'ils aient une vraie prise de
conscience des uns des autres donc ça
c'est d'aider la question de délai sur
la question des échelles on a vu aussi
des grandes marées les chefs des grandes
régions c'est compliqué à l'esra dette
sont éloignés le sénateur cards ont
évoqué l'échelle départementale
c'est sûrement une échelle sur laquelle
aussi on peut travailler à l'échelle de
quelques intercommunalités sur ces
questions foncières
j'insiste aussi sur la question de
d'objectiver les consommations ça a été
évoqué par année de l'hémione tout à
l'heure mais par aussi quelques
sénateurs on a besoin d'avoir les vrais
des outils pour observer pour objectiver
les choses que ce soit en extension
comment densification donc là aussi
quand on fait un pmu qui soient
communales ou intercommunales on prend
le temps de regarder notre capacité à
densifier à exploiter les dents creuses
dans notre commune quelle que soit leur
taille donc la question de ces outils
d'ingénierie sont importants ça fait le
lien avec ce que j'ai évoquées g20
insistent à l'importance de se prendre
en main à travers les documents
d'urbanisme que sont les pme et encore
plus quand ils sont à l'échelle
intercommunale l'échelle intercommunale
qui peut aussi être l'échelle à laquelle
on on se mobilise et en moyens
d'ingénierie on y aille l'état et je
sais pas contradictoire avec le
renforcement des moyens de l'état sur
les territoires à travers la ddt mais au
delà de la question de la consommation
foncière le mieux logés dans nos
territoires c'est aussi comment on
favorise le parcours résidentiel
parce que globalement au manque pas de
grands logements on en a plein ils sont
saouls alité sous-occupés comment on
construit peu plus tôt du petit logement
en centralité pour donner à faire vivre
le parcours résidentiel et je termine
par un dernier point devrait dire d'état
d'esprit plusieurs interventions tendant
à opposer le pouvoir de nos mères et le
pouvoir de nos intercommunalités
jeudi je redis dans nos interco tous les
élus intercommunaux sont d'abord des
élus municipaux et sur beaucoup de
politiques publiques même si on peut
débattre de certaines transfert de
compétences obligatoires sur beaucoup de
politiques publiques et le pmu on est à
un exemple ben il est d'abord le
la prise de compétence est d'abord le
fait d'une volonté locale et avec des
mécanismes de majorité qualifiée qui
permettent de dégager des consensus donc
n'opposons pas nos mères le pouvoir de
nos nerfs elle pouvoir des intercoms
c'est
c'est dommage puisque nous sommes tous
des élus municipaux et acolyte et c'est
notre outil à nous comme une aussi pour
pouvoir faire ensemble des choses qu'on
peut plus faire merci
ce débat merci beaucoup madame les mieux
vous laisse le mot de la fin
rapide
de la fin de ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
fait ce que je ressens profondément de
la part de l'ensemble des sénateurs
c'est une espèce de d'opposition entre
le rural et le milieu urbain et ça me
fait un jeu
le parlement représente le parlementaire
après les sénateurs représentent les
effectivement les maires de toutes les
communes il ya beaucoup de communes
rurales fait effectivement mais je suis
assez sûr peut-être un peu surprise
quand même de cette opposition alors que
nous souhaitons avant tout justement à
lier l'ensemble des élus et vous rallier
l'ensemble des amis de manière à
construire à construire ensemble sur le
territoire
et respecter les objectifs qui sont
fixés donc je voudrais rappeler je les
ai déjà dit tout à l'heure mais le
rappeler parce que certains certains
l'ont mal compris 22 métropole 19
millions d'habitants qui représente 1%
de
d'artificialisation depuis 2001 ce sont
des chiffres que je que je n'invente pas
qu'ils sont le résultat de l'observation
donc l'artificialisation dans les
métropoles représente 1% depuis 2009 sur
le sur sept territoires donc
effectivement les métropoles façon
générale construisent beaucoup oui mais
de façon de façon encore qu'on
reconstruise la ville sur elle-même donc
de façon un peu plus vertueuse mais tout
simplement parce que le contexte est
comme cela je voulais aussi dire que
dans les communes dans les métropoles il
y a aussi des communes rurales je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure mais il ya aussi des
communes qui ont des revenus ça peut
arriver et sur la métropole toulousaine
nous avons neuf communes qui vont qui
sont sous régime et rhénus c'est
paradoxal mais c'est comme ça voilà neuf
c'est surprenant mais c'est parce qu'un
poste est en vigueur dans avec la avec
la nomination du père louis h tout s'est
arrêté moi je note aussi que 7,7 ces
objectifs font font appel ou suscite des
réflexions sur un bon nombre de
politiques publiques en le législateur
il a pour pour la le respect du than il
a confié au père louis h vous causez lui
en charge le pen lui h le soin de porter
cette politique donc c'est dans le cadre
du pays via ce que nous devons intégrer
la politique ambitieuse de zone qui a
été porté par la loi climat et
résilience donc et on comprend bien
qu'il y aura d'autres politiques
publiques qui devront s'agréger à
l'élaboration de ce document pour bourg
accompagné toute la politique de
sobriété foncière qui a été évoquée donc
c'est un ça n'est pas que le pèlerinage
qui doit porter tout cela mais également
toutes les politiques publiques il y en
a beaucoup qui doivent accompagner cela
je j'ai noté qu'il y a des territoires
qui sont démunis en ingénierie bon c'est
vrai on va pas revenir sur ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure mais je voudrais
souligner qu'il ya des agences
d'urbanisme qui font un travail
considérable
mais il y en a pas partout effectivement
peut-être faudrait-il poussé à ce qu'il
y en ait davantage de manière à répondre
aux attentes des territoires mais
certains certains élus qui sont
peut-être ici on travaillait avec les
agences d'urbanisme qui sont les outils
qui sont là vraiment impliqué
directement impliqué dans le sujet et
puis je voudrais aborder aussi à un
moment donné il a été question de l'art
de la dent creuse a su 9 est est ce une
dent creuse qui peut être construit tout
est encore une espace agricole
d'aujourd'hui la cette occasion parler
des seuils parce que on a évoqué voilà
mais ça mais je m'arrête là on a évoqué
les cinq mais comme je n'avais pas dit
je voulais le dire donc à évoquer la
notion de seuil puisque nous attendons
un arrêté ministériel qui doit définir
si le seuil de déclenchement 19 ses 500
mètres carrés où 2500 peu importe que ce
soit l'un ou l'autre mais que ce soit
l'un ou l'autre voilà donc nous nous
insistons beaucoup là dessus pour que
les choses soient très clarifier mais il
y en ad'autres est tarifié ma femme
[Musique]
or dans l'expression j'ai fait plus que
dix minutes pour faire passer des
amendements sur pouvoir d'achat donc
merci beaucoup à vous tous nous vous
remercions vraiment pour la richesse je
voudrais juste dire que nous sommes
contrairement à peut-être ce que vous
avez ressenti madame très attentif aux
équilibres entre les territoires et a
pas opposer les territoires les uns aux
autres je dis à mes collègues nous
aurons des échanges avec le département
bien sûr et avec les régions de france
évidemment qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
écartés de cette de cette réflexion et
enfin je veux vous dire que nous sommes
en train de mettre en place un groupe de
travail multi couleurs politiques et
multi compétences ou à la au travers
quatre commissions compétentes ici qui
aura en charge la coordination avec un
travail avec vous et avec le ministre
béchu qui a appelé de ses voeux voilà et
que la première urgence pour nous va
être de retarder les échéances on a
besoin de vous pour essayer de pousser
ça qui est d'ordre législatif
malheureusement voilà merci infiniment
et pardon de ne pas avoir la correction
de vous raccompagner jean baptiste blanc
va le faire voilà pour moi nous sommes
un peu contraint par les délais comme
vous l'avez remarqué merci à mes
collègues qui ne sont pas de la
commission des affaires économiques
voilà de nous laisser délibéré voilà
merci beaucoup en pardon vraiment merci
infiniment